hey everyone and welcome to the full
course tutorial on php programming by
simplylearn
in this video we'll discuss everything
you need to know about php
now before we begin make sure to
subscribe to simply learn and do hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so let us see what we've got for you in
this video
first we'll start by a proper
introduction to php followed by learning
how to use xam software to build our
first hello world php program
then we'll learn all the basic php
programming concepts right from the very
beginning to loop scenarios
we will then move on to learning about
object oriented programming in php
next we will have a look at some php
extensions that can be integrated into
visual studio code for a better
programming experience
we will also learn about php get and
post methods followed by a tutorial on
how to implement mysql with php
php form validation
cred operations in php
php registration and login form
we will also discuss rest apis in php
followed by an extensive web development
tutorial by creating a website
next we will also work on an ecommerce
website tutorial
and finally we will have a look at the
most frequently asked php interview
questions
so without any further ado
let's get started
let us first meet rob
rob is the owner of an e-commerce
business
earlier his customers were very happy
with the products they purchased from
his website
but with more traffic and user base rob
started receiving complaints from his
customers
not related to the products but the
website itself
now the customers were facing challenges
like slow website speed bad user
experience and poor security features
like any other business owner rob wanted
to rectify the problem but he was unable
to find a solution to it
well developing his websites in php can
solve all of rob's problem and guess
what php is simple to learn and easier
to implement
let me elaborate on this
php is useful in many ways as
first and foremost it can make the
website function faster
it can create dynamic web pages and
dynamic web pages are what makes a
website more interactive
next it provides security encryption
it is a cost efficient language
it is very compatible as it works
efficiently with different databases and
programming languages
and it is platform independent which
means a php application can run on any
environment
now before moving into the details did
you know that
79.2 percent web is still powered by php
which nearly translates to 20 million
websites and 1 million web servers
now in this presentation
you'll learn about what is php
how does it work differently from a
conventional web page
what are its features
some major companies where php is
implemented
prerequisites on learning it
and finally we will have a look at the
demo for our first php program
now without further ado
let's get started
so what exactly is php php stands for
hypertext preprocessor which is a
recursive acronym
it is an open source server-side
scripting language that is embedded into
html and used for web development
now before we get overwhelmed by the
technical terms let me simplify them for
you
now for those of you who don't know open
source is a term for technology which
means it is freely available to everyone
while server-side scripting means that
from writing the code to implementing
and processing it everything is done on
the server side while the user just lays
down and enjoys the experience
now that we know what php is
let's see how a php script looks like
as you can see on the screen this is the
syntax of php
it opens with an angle bracket
question mark php and ends with a
question mark and an angle bracket
while the code comes in between them
now as you can notice
this is very similar to how html codes
are written
now let's have a look at some features
of php
now while php being a very diverse and
feature-rich language some of its main
features are listed here
let us try and understand them one by
one
first is simple
now this feature comes as a good news to
new learners since php is simple and
hence an easy to learn language
next comes flexibility
php is a highly flexible language
in conventional web pages even the
smallest of changes have to go through
the developer who changes the code to
implement them well php gives you the
flexibility to make small changes
without the intervention of the
developer itself
it is also platform independent which
means it does not require any special
plugins to run and can basically run on
any environment
next is interpreted php is an
interpreted language and does not
compile the entire code hence taking
less time
which takes us to a next feature that is
fast
websites developed in php are faster
this is why developing dynamic websites
using php is considered as the best
option
as discussed earlier too php is called
as an open source language which means
it is free to use and implement
next feature is security
the language consists of a few built-in
frameworks that provides benefits like
encryption and hence protection from
cyber attacks
next is a large php community since php
is an old language it has grown up to a
large community which is very helpful
and makes the language more stable so
that was all about features of php
moving forward let us discuss the
workflow of a php web page
how does a ph page work
so for a better understanding let us
first see how a basic html page
functions
in the basic html workflow when you open
a website on your browser
a request is sent from the browser to
the server and the server then returns
the requested page stored on it back to
the browser
now that's it
no matter what device or what purpose
you open the website for the page return
is always the same or you can say static
now what php does different is when you
open a website developed in php
a request in dot php extension is sent
to the server
into the server there exists a php
interpreter which recognizes the dot php
file and interprets it based on the
request from the browser
it pulls out data from its database and
file systems and returns a html page
personalized according to the user
now let me give you an example to make
it more clear
when you log into your account on rob's
new e-commerce website made on php it
takes your unique request to the server
and shows you products based on your
past preference and liking instead of
showing you the exact same page every
time now this makes the website dynamic
and more interactive to the user
also guys before moving forward if you
are enjoying this video please give a
thumbs up and subscribe to simply learn
for more such content
so that was all about the workflow of
php
let us discuss the companies using them
many companies have reached great
success by implementing php into their
websites
let me list down a few of them
first comes facebook the biggest social
media platform
did you know that facebook was created
entirely on php
and according to the website similar web
php is visited by users for nearly 22
billion times per month this means the
social media platform has to deal with
huge traffic volumes and php helps the
website with this
now before moving to the next website a
quick question for you guys
what is the one site everyone goes to
for information
correct it's wikipedia
and guess what it is written in php2
now platforms like wordpress which are
used to create beautiful websites itself
are also based on php
and blogging and social media channels
such as tumblr and even
multi-service platforms like yahoo which
face huge amounts of data traffic every
day uses php to function
so now that i hope you're more motivated
to learn php
let us look at some of the prerequisites
of learning it
now since php scripts as already
discussed are embedded into html codes a
basic understanding of html comes
naturally as a prerequisite
again a website cannot be complete
without the implementation of css hence
a basic understanding of css is also a
must
next is basic knowledge of programming
language now this is not necessarily a
prerequisite but if you have basic
knowledge of programming fundamentals
such as oops concept
functions and errors etc it would really
help you along the way
let's get started and learn what exactly
is zam
now zam stands for cross platform apache
server maria database php
and then finally perl
xampp is an open source application that
is developed by apache friends and is
one of the easiest ways to host a local
web server with access to mysql database
php and perl
so it is an all-in-one package
so now that we have an understanding of
what zamp is let us set up the software
on our system and then see how to use it
to run a php script
so now to set up the xampp software what
we need to do is
let us open the browser
and
download
our software
so as you can see here
apachefriends.org is the official
website from where you can download the
sam software
since we are using the windows version
we'll download it for windows
although it is available for linux and
mac os as well
now let's wait for the download to get
finished
it almost is
now
let's open the setup and install our
software right away
continue installation
next
now from here you can select all the
extra files that you want to install
along with the xampp setup or you don't
want to install
now this is the default folder for zamp
installation that is c drive zam and i
would recommend you keep it that way
i think there's some issue here
yeah well
this is the
folder for my old xampp
now
we wait for the installation to get
finished and then we'll run a quick php
script a welcome or hello world kind of
script to see how this zam software
functions along with php
now the installation is almost done
we'll just wait for a few
now the installation is complete and
now
let us open the control panel to check
if it's
done correctly
yes
everything seems fine now so this is the
control panel for the xampp software
which includes all the services provided
by it and in our php tutorials we'll be
mainly using the apache server and the
mysql one so you need to click on apache
server
started and mysql
now apache server will show you the
default port on which it is running now
to check if xampp is correctly installed
on your system
let's open the browser again
and type
localhost
now this will open up the dashboard for
the xampp application
let's click on phpmyadmin
and
the information is available here so
the installation is complete
similarly we'll install the visual
studio port since i've already installed
the software on my system i will not be
doing that now
let us come to the important part
let us redirect to
c drive
and there we have a exam installed
open the xampp folder and locate htdocs
now this is the folder where all your
php files codes and website related data
will be stored
now we'll open the htdocs and let us
create a new folder here
since it will be a first program let us
name it
first
php
now let's open our code editor that is
visual studio code
click on open folder
locate to
xampp
htdocs
and the folder we created first php
as you can see let me close this first
as you can see first php folder is
visible here
let us create our first php file
let's name it
hello dot php now don't forget the dot
php extension otherwise the code will
not run now since a browser only
understands html code we will have to
embed the php script into the html code
itself so let's begin
let me zoom it a little bit so you can
see clearly
let me
add a heading so h1 will be too big
let's keep it to h2
my
first
php
webpage
let's write our first php script so a
php script begins with an opening
angular bracket question mark
php
now
we'll write the php script that is echo
hello world now echo acts as a print
function which prints any string that is
in front of it in this case it will
display hello world onto the web page
let's close the script with a question
mark and a closing angular bracket
and also close our html code
now before running a web page let us
first check if the web server is still
active
yes the web server is still running
so let's open the browser
type localhost now type the name of the
folder that you have created that is
first
php
now as you can see our hello.php file is
presented let's click on it
and as you can see our first web page is
visible
which shows the heading my first php web
page and the hello world from a php
script in this video on php programming
we're going to discuss different php
concepts from the very basics such as
syntax hello world program up until
learning how to collect form data using
php scripts and also cover a lot more
concepts in between now what we need to
do is to use visual studio code
what we do is we go to c drive
zap folder or wherever you have
installed your xampp server we go to
that folder
locate htdocs
and let us now create another folder
and you can name it
anything that you want to based on your
project
since we are discussing the concepts let
us
name it concepts
now right click on it and here as you
can see it shows open with code
when you click on it
you can see that it opens visual studio
code for you
along with the concepts folder that we
just created now this is where you will
create all your files for your project
and will be writing all your all of your
php scripts
now let's create the first php file from
here
new file
let us name it tutorial
dot php
and
see how a php syntax looks like
so a php syntax begins with an angular
opening bracket question mark
php
and ends with a question mark and a
closing angular bracket
while
the
php script
goes
in between
so this is the very basic syntax of how
php scripts are written
now let us move on and see how to write
a hello world program using a php script
so
to print something on php
echo is used
now to use echo what you need to do is
just write the string that you want to
print in front of it
and save the program
so
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
let us close it
and
save the file
now i am going to show you how to use
the sam software in order to run php
scripts
go
and open your xampp control panel
and from the control panel you have to
start this first service that is apache
now this is going to start a local web
server on your system
now open your browser
go to a new tab and type localhost
followed by the name of the folder that
we just created into htdocs that was
concepts
and hit enter
here you can see the file that we just
created
tutorial.php and when you click on it
you can see your first program visible
here hello and welcome to simply learn
now suppose you have a program that
needs to print this exact same string
again and again throughout the program
so
what are you going to do
type the entire echo statement
through your code
or make it simpler
now to make it simpler what we need to
do is we need to go back to our code
and discuss the concept of
variables
now to create a variable
what we need to do is we need to
use this dollar sign
followed by the name of the variable you
can name it anything you want so let us
name it str
and type
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
so
this is a first variable now this
variable str stores this string value
also you can create different variables
for different purposes such as if you
want to store a number suppose
so
you can store number five
and
suppose you want to store a floating
variable
and that would be float and a floating
variable is a number of decimal points
so 7.6
so now we have three variables
in a
program now one thing to notice if
you're coming from a different
programming language is that you don't
need to
define the type of variable in php that
is if it is a string number or a
floating variable
now to print this
we can use echo but when you want to
print a variable in echo you need to do
things a little differently
so
let us start with h1 heading
now to print a variable what you need to
do is you need to use
dot followed by the name of the variable
that would be
str
and another dot
followed by if you want to type
something
along with the variable
i'm going to copy this code
and paste it
now
let us change the size of the headings
and also change a variable so in the
second line we are going to print num
and in the third
the float that we created
so now we have all of our variables into
our echo
now let us save this program and see
what it does
so as you can see
the variables are printed on your
program and you don't have to write them
again and again you can simply write
name of the variable along with echo and
dot
and print it along
now that we know about variables
suppose you want to print the names for
different laptop brands available in the
market
now what you're going to do
do you create different variables for
each name that is a variable for hp a
variable for lenovo variable for a
source
or do you want a single variable to
store store all of the names of the
laptop brands available
now with arrays it is possible to store
different information
of the same data type that is
integer string
under a
single
variable
the condition is all of the
data that is stored under the variable
should have the same data type
now
let us see how array works
now
array
stores multiple values in a single
variable as we already discussed
now to make an array
first what we need to do is
name a variable
laptop
brand
and
type in
array function
and under that function
we are going to write the names of
different laptop brands that is hp
with separated by commas
lenovo
asus
and
dell
so
suppose these are the four laptop brands
that are available in the market in your
area
now
what you need to do is you need to print
what is
in this
particular variable that is laptop brand
so
to print it
you need to first create
variable dump now what variable dump
does is
it as you can see here
it
exports the variable that is in its
function
now
we are going to
write the variable that we just created
into the variable dump function and it
will just return the data type and value
now suppose you want to print it
so to print it what we need to do is
just add echo in front of it
okay now before moving on to seeing the
result of this program
let us just
make this part of the code
inactive
now to do that
we are going to learn a new concept in
between that is comments
so comments are the lines in a code that
are not
executed while
the program is run
so
a single line comment starts with two
slash
and anything written in front of it it
does not run along with the code
so
these comments are very useful when
you're writing a
code
to make your code readable and more
understandable by any coder who will
or might later on using the code that
you just created now suppose what we can
do with
comments is
i'm going to write a comment just in
front of it
this
is a
string
variable
now
after these
slashes
anything written is not executed when
i'm going to run the program
also now
what do you do if you want to make this
whole part of the code not functioning
do you add
two slashes in front of everything
or you can use a much simpler method
that is multi multi-line comments to use
multi-line comments what you're going to
do is
you slash
star
this marks the start of the multi-line
code and
to end this use star and slash again
and everything in bitbeam does not run
when you're going to run your program
so
we will now see
how this
array works
we will just
reload this page and as you can see
hp lenovo asus and del are visible here
also you might notice
this array 4 shows the length of the
array
and this shows
the position where all of these
strings are inside the array that is an
array starts with the zero position not
one but zero so the first would be zero
position that is hp
and then one lenovo and subsequently
asus and dell
now suppose you just want to print the
second variable in your array what you
need to do is you need to go back to
your code and
in front of the variable you need to
write the position that you want to
print
under square brackets that is the second
position
in array would be number one
and save the code
go back to the browser
and only the second
array is the second
variable in the array is visible
now suppose instead of a variable you
want to create a value that you don't
want to be changed throughout your
entire program
so
consonants are used for the same purpose
now consonants are very much like
variables except that once they are
defined they cannot be changed or
undefined
so
let us see how consonants work first
we will
put this code
under a comment
and
now start writing a consonant
so to define or create a consonant what
you need to do is
use the
define function
and inside the define function what you
need to do is
you need to
write the name of the
consonant
and
okay first let us write the name of the
consonant
suppose
laptops
followed by
the value
of the
hp
consonant
lenovo
and
asus
and that's it and you close the define
function and there you have defined your
consonant in your php script now this
cannot be changed or undefined
throughout your program
now to print it what you need to do is
type echo followed by the name of the
consonant that you just created so the
name of the consonant is laptops
save the code
go back
and hp lenovo and asus
are visible here
you can also create consonant errors
along with a normal consonant now to
create a consonant array
you just need to add a square bracket
plus a second
let me close this one
separated by
commas
and now we have
the names of the laptop as an array
which
by the way cannot be changed or
undefined through your throughout your
code just like any other consonant
now suppose you want to just print the
name of the third laptop that is
available in the market
now what you need to do is you need to
write the position and the third
position in case of areas would be
number two
save
and only asus is visible here
so this is how consonants and variables
work in php
now before moving on to the next section
let me give you another situation
now suppose i want you to print
a number only and only if it is greater
than 7.
how do you do that
now since it is a condition conditional
statements are used to perform different
actions based on different conditions
now some of the conditional statements
include in php
are if
if else
if else if else and switch and we're
going to discuss them one by one
no so the first one is if
now
let me create a variable let us name it
bear
and
write the value 8.
now
the example that we just discussed if we
want to check
if
this variable is greater than 7 and only
and only then
print the variable on our screen
now to do that what we need to do is
type in if
and in the bracket we need to type the
condition that we're going to check that
is if
variable
greater than 7
now use curly brackets
and inside the curly bracket
write the code that you want to execute
only and only if the condition in of
this
if is met
so we need to print this variable
so echo
where
and go and save it now go back
and reload and you can see it is printed
here
now let us go back and change the value
of the variable to 5
and save it
go back reload
and as you can see
nothing is printed on the screen since
the condition that we just mentioned
inside if does not meet
now suppose
i tell you that
if the condition does not meet you have
to print
a string
saying that the condition does not did
not meet
how do you do that
to do it what you need to add after if
is
else
and else does not need to have a
condition since as
the english
word suggests it is else
which means the condition of if did not
meet
and inside the else we're going to write
the code
echo
the
condition
did
not meet
save it
the condition did not meet
now time for another condition
now suppose i want i ask you to check if
a number is divisible by 2
3 or both
how do you do that
now to do that first
let us
create a number
six
now check if
variable
percent
2
is equal to equals to 0 now what this
shows is this
brings out the remainder and if the
remainder is 0 that means it is
divisible by 2.
and we need to add one more condition
here
[Music]
and
variable
percent
three
equals to equals to zero
and
what this does is it checks if both of
these conditions are true that is
if the number
inside the variable is divisible by both
2 and 3
we will display
divisible
by
both
now
what we need to do is we need to
check if it is divisible by 2
so
else
if
since it is else if we need to add a
condition in it to else if
variable
person
to
equals to equals to
zero
echo
div is
built
by
two
similarly
divisible by
three
another you can add as many else if
statements as you want
and the final else will show
okay
let us go back and save our program
since a variable is six
it should show divisible by both
and you can see it shows exactly the
same divisible by both
now let us change the value
and see if our program works
so what we are going to do is we are
going to change the value to 4
save a program
and run it again
this by two
similarly
nine
divided by 3
and finally
13
not divided by either 2 or 3.
so this is how you can make use of if
else if and else statements
now the next conditional statement is
switch statement now the switch
statement is used to perform different
actions based on different conditions
so let me again give you a situation so
that you understand better
so suppose
you're playing a game
which has four different levels and
first level is easy medium hard and
extreme
so
you need to print that
now what will you do you can also use if
else's but it's a lot of code
switch statement makes it a lot simpler
and more readable
so
what we need to do is we need to
type in switch
okay first what we need to do is first
we need to create a variable
so a variable
suppose
let us name it level
and
level is three
to create a switch statement you need to
type in switch and
enter the name of the variable that will
be passed into the switch statement to
check for the conditions
level
and it also begins with a curly bracket
and inside
the search statement what you need to do
is you need to type
case
that is
the first case would be case
one
followed by
a colon
and the statement that you want to
execute that is
echo
you
are
playing
at
easy
level
and
since you want
your program to stop here itself what
you need to do is
you need to type in
break
similarly for rest of the levels i'll
just copy this code here
two three and four
and just make the changes
and
similar to if else statements you also
need to add
another statement that would be
default
if any of the conditions are not met in
the switch statement suppose the value
of your variable is 20 which does not
make any sense to the game
then
what you need to do is
you need to
display
a default error message and that would
be
invalid
input
and you also need to
end the switch statement
with
a curly braces
and end the
php program
all right
let us save it
go to a browser
and run you are playing at hard level
i guess you must have understood the
concept
let us just one more time
change the value of the variable to 20
save it
go back
invalid input
so this is how the conditional
statements in php work
next what we're going to talk about is
php loops
now suppose you want to run a block of
code or a part of code again and again
and again or in other words in loop
so php has that functionality known as
php loops
to do the same task
now there are different types of php
loops available that is while do while
and for loops which we will be
discussing
in this part of the video
now let us start with the while loop now
the while loop
loops through a block of code as long as
the condition that you have entered or
specified in the while loop is true
so
let me just
remove it
now to write a while loop what you need
to do is
type while
followed by
the condition
and to write the condition what we need
to first do is
let us create a variable
and
we'll
give it a value of 2.
now the condition
which we are going to write is this is
just an example
so
if
or while
the value of variable
is
less than equals to
10
and then we follow along with the curly
braces
and type the code that we want to run
again and again until the value of a
variable becomes 10
or
till the value of a variable is less
than 10.
suppose
number
and then the variable that is
where
and that's about it
now what we need to do is we need to
increase the value of the variable else
this code this code will run
for an infinite amount of time and the
system might crash
so
to increase the variable in each
iteration
what we need to do is we need to use the
plus plus operator
which will increase the value of the
variable by 1 in each iteration
now we we're going to save the code
and run it number 2 3 4 5 6 7
and so on
let me just
add
break here and you can see all of the
numbers up until 10
are visible here and after 10 the loop
just stops
so let me
explain it again
so
what we are doing is we are writing
while
along with the condition until
then the code is supposed to be run
again and again
so the condition is if the value of the
variable
is less than or equals to 10 since a
value of
value of our variable is 2 the condition
is true so the code inside of this vial
is executed and the code will display
the value of the number
and the
variable
value will increase with each iteration
until it becomes greater than 10 and
then
the loop will exit
now the do while loop is very very
similar to the while one the only
difference being in case of a do while
loop
a
code
this this code will execute at least
once
i'll show you how it works
so
in case of do while
we start with two
curly braces
let us use this same
example
and after the curly braces what we do is
we
write
while along with the condition
that is
equals to 10.
let me just
okay
now let me tell you what do we need low
value suppose
the value of a variable
is
11 now since the condition
does not meet
in case of the while loop it will not
even run once now suppose you want to
display the current value of the
variables whether or not if it meets a
condition at least once
so
in case of do while
it will first go into this do loop
run the code and then after the do loop
is complete this part of the code is
complete it will go on to the vile part
and check the condition
now if the condition does not meet the
loop will end here and if it meets it
will continue until the condition does
not meet the while part
so it will run at least once
now
save this
and go back to a browser
and reload this program and as you can
see number 11
is visible here
so
do while is helpful
in some cases which you'll realize as
long as
you start coding more and more
now next up is follow
now for loop is used when
we already know how many times you want
the loop to run so for loop is used when
you want to run a piece of code a
specific number of times
now let me show you how it works
now the for loop is written in three
parts here we don't need to define a
variable beforehand
the first part of the for loop is
defining the value of the variable so
variable
is equals to let us
value it at one
now we want to make it
run till suppose six values
so what we need to do is
we need to
write the condition
in the second part of the for loop
if variable less than equals to 6
and in the third part will be the
incremental part so as you can notice in
while and do while we put the
incremental part inside the block of the
code here the incremental part is inside
the for function itself
variable plus plus
and then we start with the curly braces
and we write the
code similar to
i'll just
copy it from here
and now let us
just save it and print to show you
how it works
number one two three four five and six
now these loops are a very important
aspect of programming and you all should
try out different problems based on
loops by yourself
now next up in php is php functions
now functions are very very useful and
very important part of programming in
any language
functions are of two types
built-in functions and user-defined
functions
now built-in functions are the functions
that are already present inside the
framework of your programming language
a very popular example
of a function built-in function of php
is echo echo is a function that is
already built in php and is used to
print out variables strings and values
on the screen
now user defined functions are functions
you create yourself
to use a code
repeatedly in your program
so i'll explain you with while writing
the code itself
so suppose you want to use this for code
four or five times in your program
so
or even more maybe 10 20 30 40 100 times
in your program if you're writing a very
very large program you want to
print or use this part of the code 100
times in your program what do you do do
you write this entire code or copy paste
this entire code again and again 100
times and make your code lengthier or do
you just want to use this piece of code
from here
from anywhere in your program
now to do that we need to
put this piece of code inside a user
defined function
so how do we do that
we do that by
writing
function
followed by
suppose you want to call
this function
a name
name
and start with curly braces
now this is a user defined function
named name
now inside this name function
is a piece of code this
for
now how do we reuse it
i'll show you in a second
so
suppose you are a long way from your
code from this code you don't even know
where it is
you want to use
this code again after writing hundreds
of lines of code so how do you do it you
just type the name of the function
that is name
and close it that's about it this is
called calling a function so it is
similar to calling a friend for help
so here you just called your friend name
to execute this part of the code
here
save
and where there are no changes since the
output will be the same
let us make some changes
add another echo
i am
going to
run it
again
later
and call this function again
save it
and as you can see
once the function is called the output
is printed and i'm going to run it again
later
and then again the function is called
and it
uses the same piece of code again and
again and again
see how simple coding can be
when you know what to use when
now let's move ahead and understand the
concepts of oops in php
so as you can see on the screen i have
listed down the eight concepts of oops
that we will be discussing today first
is class
next comes objects then its member
function and member variables then
constructor and destructor
inheritance and finally it is
polymorphism
now let's walk through each of the
concepts one by one
first is class
it is a blueprint of an object that
provides initial values for the state
a class consists of both data and
functions and data and functions
together are called objects
now let's first have a look at the class
let me create a file
named class.php
and let us write the code first
so
here i have defined a class by using the
class keyword
followed by fruit which is the class
name
next i have added a pair of curly braces
and added the entire properties and
methods within the braces so as you can
see on the screen we have declared a
class named fruit
that contains two properties called name
and color
along with that i have also added two
methods
set name and get name
now now the purpose of these methods is
for setting and getting the name
property
so let me give you some in important
information so when you define a class a
variable in it is called property while
a function is known as method
now let us execute the code and see the
output
let's go to the browser and type
localhost followed by the file name
here's a file class.php
and as you can see on the screen the
code is running perfectly
now that was about the class
next comes objects
so it is an instance of a class
basically
a variable holds a date of a class now
we define a class once
and create as many objects in it
so for a better understanding let me
give you an example
suppose a car is a class
so mercedes benz and bmw would be
objects
now let's see objects
classes are incomplete without objects
so we can add as many objects as we want
from a class
and every single object has the
properties and methods defined in the
class but those objects will have
different property values
so objects of a class are created using
the new keyword
now let me open the code editor
and let's
create another file
called
obj.php
so this code will be the same
let's
copy and paste it here
now let me type the code for object
[Music]
as you can see i have used the new
keyword to create object of the class
fruit
similarly
banana
would be another object
and now we'll use the set name function
to set
the name to apple
on this object on the apple object that
we have created
similarly
we will
set the name
for the banana object
there's an extra bracket here let's move
it
now moving forward let us type the code
to display
what we have added into the objects
for this can you guess which method will
be using
yes the get name method
will be used to display
the name saved onto the object using the
set name method
now that our code is complete
let us run and check
if it's working correctly
let me go back
and refresh
now here we have our object.php file
yes the code runs perfectly the fruit
program
and it is displaying apple and banana
from the two objects that we created
i hope now you have clearly understood
the concept moving on to the next one
let's talk about the member variable and
member function
a member variable is defined within a
class
the data can be accessed by the member
functions alone now once the object is
built these variables are called
attributes of the object
whereas member function is defined
within a class and is used to access
object data so next comes constructor
so it allows an individual to allot an
object's properties
while the object creation
while a destructor is a function that is
called when the object stops working
we will have a look at the constructor
program
so constructor allows an individual to
alert an object's properties while the
object creation
now suppose you build a program using
constructor function
php will automatically call the
construct function while creating an
object from a class also remember that
when you write the construct function
always prefix it with two underscores
now let's have a look at the example
where we will be using a constructor
function with calling the set name
method
now this set name function is often used
when you assign a value to the name
attribute
now let's open the code editor and
create a constructor file
[Music]
we'll again create the two properties
named
name
and color
now we will create a constructor with
two underscores
and a construct keyword
and i'll give the two properties as
attributes to the constructor
now in this
program will be using the constructor
function
as the set
method
to set the names
and color of a fruit by default
during the object creation itself
we still need to create the get
functions
so
now let's create an object to invoke the
constructor
now since the constructor has attributes
we will have to give the values for the
attributes as well
so the fruit would be
strawberry
and color
would be pink
so this creates a new object and it
gives
the values to the constructor
uh
in the php script
and our html code as well
let us save the code and check if it's
working
let's go back refresh
now constructor file is visible let's
click on it and yes
so
when the object strawberry is created
the attributes we have given to the
constructor strawberry and the color
pink were already
assigned to it
and it is displayed in the browser
itself
now that the constructor program is done
next let's see an example of how a
destructor works
let's open the code editor
create another file
destructor.php
now the destructor code will be very
similar to the constructor one so we
will copy the code
into the destructor file and make some
changes
so
let us remove this we don't need it
and write our destructor function
so destructive function is written
similarly
how constructor function is written so
it starts with two underscores and a
destruct keyword
it does not have an attribute
now why did we delete the get functions
is because
we will be using the destructor
for it
also we won't be needing this
just the object creation is sufficient
now let's save our program and
do the drill again
open the browser
here a destructor file is visible
and it shows the fruit strawberry and
the color is pink so when the object
function is complete
and the program ends the destructor
function is called which displays the
strawberry and the color blink
now
comes inheritance so it derives new
classes or child classes from the parent
class
however inheritance can have its own
properties and methods too
so inheritance has two classes
first is parent class and the other one
is a child class
now let's talk about each of them in
detail
so parent class is otherwise called a
base class that is inherited from
another class
and a child class is a subclass that
inherits from another class
a child class can have sub classes and
derive classes
now let's have a look at the inheritance
program
so the child class is derived from all
the properties and methods from the
subclass
in addition it can have its own
properties and methods too
so an inherited class is defined by
using the extends keyword
let's look at an example
let's open the code editor so i've taken
the liberty to create the
inheritance.php file
and write some of the code that we have
already written so i'll be writing only
the code that is necessary for the
inheritance part
now also remember when you derive a
child class from a parent class only the
public methods are derived into the
child class
so we will be creating the methods as
public
in order them to be
inherited
made this function public
let's
end this class
and create another class in order
to inherit this class
so we will name
another class as
cherry
extends
fruit
and we'll create another function for
cherry
so this function is exclusive to cherry
so we have given a message through this
method
now let's create an object
cherry
new
cherry
and
give the values for the attributes
of this constructor
let's save the code
and check if it's working
well there seems to be an error
now let's try to resolve it
okay got it so we
created the object
within
the cherry class so it got localized
what we need to do is put that code
outside of the cherry class
and it should work fine now
yes so is cherry a fruit or a berry a
cherries or fruit and the color of the
fruit is red
and now we will talk about the last
concept that is polymorphism so
polymorphism has many forms
the same function is utilized for
different purposes
it has a class with a variety of
functions simultaneously sharing a
common interface
so inherited methods are overridden by
redefining the methods in the derived
class
now let me write the code to make it
clear
so already created the polymorphism php
file
i have copied the inheritance code
into the polymorphism part
and then now we will make the changes
into the derived class that is cherry
so let's create a property named
wait
now to
override the constructor and the intro
function
from the fruit class we will have to
create the same functions
in the derived class also
now this function construct has got one
extra attribute in comparison to this
function construct
you
let's create the intro function too
you
now a code is ready
let us create another object
to invoke
the functions
now did you notice what we did here
so
when we created the object cherry for
for the cherry class we gave three
attribute values instead of two
in order to invoke this construct
function
not this
let us run it and check
so it runs perfectly it displays the
fruit the color and the weight
in this video we will discuss some php
extensions that can be and should be
added in visual studio code to make php
programming a little easier
and a life's a little simpler
now to check the extensions available or
search any of them we need to go to this
tab that is the extensions tab
now these are the already installed
extensions on our system
and from here you can search
extensions available in the visual
studio code marketplace
now the first extension and a must-have
extension is
php
intellifence
now to understand what it does
let me go back to
the explorer
and open a test.php
so what i'm going to do is
write some
basic php built-in functions
let us say
php
info
so
what you need to notice is when you type
php info
it shows a suggestion it is from the
built-in feature that is already
installed into the visual studio code
but when you click on this that's it
now i'll show you the difference
go back to extensions
and install php intelligence
now go back to your test file
and again
type php
info now as you can notice you can see
two php infos here now when you click on
this one
you can see all the details about this
function
available
right here
so this is what
php intel fence is it intelligently
suggests and autofills parts of your
code to make your programming simpler
and much easier
now moving on to a second extension our
second extension will be
php
mess detector
now what phpmes detector does is it
analyzes your php code on every save
now there's no additional setup required
if php is already installed on your
system which already is
so
to see what it does
let us install it
now before that
let us go back to test dot
and let me just
open this
now here you can see the output of your
code so if you go back to phpmes
detector install it
and go back to your code you can see
phpmes detector is visible here and
after
everything
that you write
it analyzes your code after every save
and it is pretty useful while writing
big and complex php
codes now let's move on to the next
extension
which would be
php
auto
close stack now what php auto close tag
as the name suggests does is when you
open a tag when you whenever you write a
tag that is suppose html
or body etc etc anything that you write
it will automatically close the tag and
you can simply start writing the code so
this extension has saved me a lot of
time finding what problem is in my code
fixing the bug when actually it was just
that i did not close the tag
so
suppose
i write html and as you can see it
automatically closes the tag and you can
simply start writing the code
now moving on to our next step that
would be
phpfmt that is php
formatter
now
what it does is it formats your code
with proper indentation and
well your code looks much more readable
after this
so
let me just show you
i've already created a test2.php
let me just close this
so as you can see
this code is not indented at all and
one might have trouble understanding
what is going on and what part of code
is under what
loops and
statements so
we go back to our extension php
formatter
install it
go back to test one
sorry test2
now
when you right click
after installing this extension you can
see format document section available
then
when you click on it
the code gets automatically
indented and looks much more readable
now so as you may notice
all these codes under comes under the if
conditions
and
that's the rest of the code looks much
more readable now
now the last extension that i am going
to discuss is
php
debug
now this extension
you may not use it on a very regular
basis but this extension is very helpful
when you want to debug your code and see
what's wrong with it
all the instructions on how to use this
extension are written alongside it and
how to install how to use how to
install extra servers in order to
completely utilize its potential
since this extension is a table adapter
between visual studio code and x debug
website that was developed by derek
ruthens
so
i'm going to install it
and this is the very website x debug
where
any of your code is debugged
so these are some of the extensions that
you need to begin or ease your journey
into php
there are a lot more extensions
available for php
and you can explore more into them as
you move forward
we will look at php in get and post
so all of us know that php is a
scripting language for creating web
pages but what is get in post
there are two ways the browser client
can send information to the web server
the get method and the post method
let's understand get method in detail
first
the get method sends the encoded user
information appended to the page request
the page and the encoded information are
separated by the question mark character
now let's know more about the get method
the get method produces a long string
that appears in your server logs in the
browser's location box
it is restricted to send up to 1024
characters only
also
never use the get method if you have a
password or other sensitive information
to be sent to the server since it will
show in the browser's location box
next the get can't be used to send
binary data like images or word
documents to the server
also the data sent by get method can be
accessed using the query string
environment variable
now let us try writing a code to
understand the get method better
so as you can see we have got the output
but if you look at the link
it has an ampersand symbol along with
the username and age we entered
now before the browser sends the
information it encodes it using a scheme
called url encoding in this scheme name
value pairs are joined with equal sign
and different pairs are separated by the
ampersand
also as we discussed earlier the page
request
and the encoded information is separated
by a question mark sign
so that was all about the get method
moving on to the next one let's have a
look at the post method
now the post method transfers
information via http headers
the information is encoded and described
in the get method and put into a header
called query string
the post method does not have any
restrictions on data size to be sent
the post method can be used to send asci
as well as binary data and the data sent
by post method goes through http header
so security depends on http protocol
used by using secure http you can make
sure that your information is secure
now let's have a look at the code now
now you must be wondering if both the
methods give the same output so what is
the difference between them
well the major difference between post
and get method is that get method
carries request
parameters appended in url string as you
can see here the parameters are visible
in the url
while post carries request parameters in
message body which makes it more secure
way of transferring data from client to
the destination as you can see there is
no information in the url
now a lot of people have raised a
request to create a code on the request
method too so let me tell you the
request variable can be used to get the
result from form data sent with both the
get and post methods
let us try out a code for the request
method too
as you can see we have got the output
today we will learn how to link mysql
database to your html code with the help
of php
now to do that we will build a simple
registration form whose data will be
uploaded to the mysql database
and in this tutorial you will learn how
to create that database how to link it
to your web page and also how to delete
the tables or entries from the database
now before proceeding i am expecting
that you guys have some basic
understanding of html php and mysql
so
without further ado
let's get started
also guys for this tutorial we'll be
working on zam and visual studio code
now let's get started
so first we'll open the c drive zamp
folder htdocs and let us create a
folder let's name it
tutorial
and open the visual studio code and
start writing the code for a
registration page
let's create a file
and name it index.php
you
let's give the title as registration
form
and close the head
now let's give
some heading to a registration page
now to make it a little more interesting
let us suppose the registration page is
for a blood donation camp
so
we will
name our heading as the blood donation
camp
and
close it
now let's give some
background color
to the page
now to give
some background color we need to first
know the code for it
let's search for color codes
well i like the saffron one
let's copy the code
paste it here
[Music]
a heading for the
page registration form
now as you can notice i
wrote this heading as h1 and this one
has h2 since this will be a little
smaller from the first one
let's close the div
and write a form
now
in this action part
write connect dot php and this is the
file which we'll be creating later in
order to connect our registration page
to the database
and method
as
post
let's name it user
so the first
entry would be
name
input type
would be
text
and we have to give
every entry a name
in order to use it in the php code to
connect to a database
let's give this name
name
now what i did here is i put the
required keyword here which would make
it compulsory in to
fill this
section of the form
in order to continue
i'm giving these break lines to
not make the form
clumsy
email
so
naturally this would be the label for
email
and let me skip ahead with this section
so i have written the code
for the different fields that we are
going to have in a registration page
so the first one was name second email
third would be the phone number and
fourth obviously the blood group
of the person registering
as you can notice i have given necessary
type
different fields so for email i've given
the type as email
for blood group text and phone as text
in case someone wants to enter the
entire phone number with the country
code
so now let us create an input button
that would be submit
and
name
let us keep it submit
id would be
submit
let's close our form
and close the
web page too
now let's save it and check
if it's working correctly
now let's open the browser
before that
first we need to open the sam control
panel and
start our apache server and mysql server
and now let us go to the localhost
type a folder name that is tutorial
and open the form
well this seems to be a problem the
other fields are not visible
let's open a code and see
what did we do wrong
yeah well there's a spelling mistake
here
and since i copy pasted the code
the mistake got copy pasted too
well
let's save it again and check if it's
working correctly
yes perfect
now before moving on to creating our
connect.php file we first need to create
our database itself
so first we need to go to zam control
panel and click on admin
now this will open the php my admin
section
where
we will go to new
and create a database
okay let us name our database as
test1
let us give it five fields and name it
you
source
first field would be id
and it would be auto implemented
second we will name it as name
250
email
this will also be worker
third one would be
phone
variable characters since people can
enter the plus sign
to enter the
country codes
and finally we will have our blood
group
and let's create our
table here
well as you can see this is a structure
of the table and the table is created
now when you click on browse
it will show you the data in this table
itself since we haven't entered any data
yet it is blank
now let's
open up
code editor and create a file
connect
dot
php and
let's get started
now here we will have to enter
the name we gave to us submit button
and that would be submit
now we will create a variable to
create a connection and we'll be using
the mysqli
underscore
connect function to do that
[Music]
here we will have to enter the name of
the server since we our server is the
locally hosted server so we will have to
type localhost
now the
type of user that would be root
now the third part is for the password
since we don't have a password for our
database it would be blank
and the fourth would be the name of our
database that is test one
now we will also check
if connection
is not complete
we will have to display an error
connection field
now in this if condition we will check
if the entries in the fields
of the registration form
are null or not
we will have to do the same for the
second
second one was
sorry i did not enter the
yeah
email
a third entry
was
phone
and a fourth and final entry would be
the blood group
i think we're done here
[Music]
now we will have to create
variables
to pick data from the
registration fields in a registration
page
now this post
will be picking data
what we'll be entering here
now here we will have to enter
the name we have given
here
so for the name field we have given the
name as name itself so we'll be writing
it here
let's
copy this code
and make the changes
this would be
email
let us also name it email
this would be
phone
this would also be bone and
last one would be
blood group
because i am naming the these variables
same as the name i've given because
naming everything differently would just
create confusion in your code
now let us enter these details into our
[Music]
database now insert into sql command
now this
would be
the table name
users
name
email
phone
and
blood group
now
we will have to
send the respective values
that would be the
variables that we just created
so first would be
name second would be email
phone
and
black group
now that we have entered the
data into the database let's create a
query
connect it
to the command
and give a message if it's successful or
not
and to successful
else
error
occurred
let us close our php script here
and save the code
and let's see if it's working
so
let's go back to registration form and
give some
details to it
so
let us name
sam
sam at the rate
mail.com
would be one two three four five six
seven eight and the blood group
can be o positive
well there's some error that we've
experienced
on line four
okay
let's see
yeah we did not close this
okay let's save it
and try again
another on line 12
what do we have here now
okay so this is my sql i not mysql
save
resend the form and entry successful now
the entry is successful
you need to go to your database which
i've shown to you earlier
go to the table users
and
we can see the details present here sam
sam at the rate mail.com the phone
number and the blood group
so now that we know how to create a
database
link our database to a html form
and see the details into the database
entered
we can also delete these details
from this phpmyadmin section itself
so as you can see
to delete this field i just have to
click on this delete button
okay and the field is gone
also if you want to delete this users
go to your database
click on users and click on drop
what it will do is it will drop the
entire table
and if you want to delete your database
itself click on this database
icon
and click on drop the database
now this will remove the entire database
and all the tables associated with it
now let's enter
one more detail set of details to double
check it
let us give it mac
that would be
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
and the blood group would be a positive
and the entry is successful
so to check it we need to go to a
database our table users
and there we have it math mac address
mail.com and the
rest of the details today we are going
to have a video session on php form
validation
so what does this actually mean
okay well let me give you an example
here so when you try to create an
account on facebook or instagram you
submit a form and then that form is
cross verified with the code written in
the backend
so today we are going to do the same
process in this video
now we will have a look at two demos now
in the first demo we will create a form
and in the second one we will validate
it
so let's get started with the first demo
but first things first
let's quickly open
c drive xampp folder htdocs and
create a folder
let's name it validation
and open our code editor here
and let's create a first file
form dot php
now i am going to write the code for the
registration form
you
now here what we're doing is we are
creating the different variables for the
form
and we are setting it to empty values
let me put that in a comment too
you
this
now as you can see the
form will contain full name email
number comment gender and age
now for this demo the username
email and mobile number fields will be
text input elements while the comment
field will be a text area
let's write the next rest of the
now we are defining the
test input function which we are calling
in the above if statement
you
okay
let's start creating the form
and add the method to
post
action would be
up
okay
you
so i skipped ahead and created all the
details
required in the form so the details
would be full name
its input type would be text
just
yet
okay now
second would be email
similarly number
h comment now notice the comment would
be a text area instead of a simple input
type
gender
and a submit button
now the form is complete
we have to write another php script to
display the details
you
[Music]
i'll just skip ahead in this part too so
now that we can display all of the
variables from the form let's close
the php script
and also
close our
form
now let me explain some parts of the
code to you before we move on to
the web page part
so
here we have
post
so this function is used at the time of
form submission now during that time the
form data is sent with
method
equals to post
second would be the server section
now this server php self is a global
variable that returns the file name of
the code
now also html special characters
function converts special characters to
html entities now this prevents
attackers from exploiting the code by
injecting html or javascript codes
that is cross site referencing scripting
attacks in forms
so now that we know what these functions
do
let us jump and see if a webpage works
okay
for that first open sam control panel
and start the apache server
and now let's open the browser
and type localhost followed by the
folder name that would be
validation
and then a file name form.php
so yes the form looks good let's
add some name to it
email
xyz.com
number is optional but let's add some
number to it
it would be 20
comment would be
hello
welcome to
simplylearn gender would be male and
let's click here
yes so our input is visible and the form
works perfectly
now let's move on ahead with our second
demo that is validating a form now we
will be writing a code but with slight
variations now the fields like full name
email address and websites will be added
here and these three fields will show an
error if an incorrect input is given now
however the code is validated against
the input and returns an alert message
if an incorrect data is entered
let's go to the code editor
and create another file
and let's name it
validate.php
and write
another code for it
[Music]
now added some
color for the
error that will be shown into the
form
again
let us write comment for it define
variables
and set to
empty
and our variables would be named err
that is error
similarly email
here
gender
trr
and the rest of fields
so
now let's give the else command for it
now if
no error found or the field entered is
correct
the name will be displayed as we
displayed the name in the form.php file
with the help of post
name
now what we are going to do is
now we will check if name only contains
letters and white spaces
so
you
and this would be
er
you
now we will check
if the email address is well formed or
not
to do that we will again use an if
statement
i think i have used
emi
somewhere
since it's showing here emai
so let's check before it throws an error
in a code
there's email yeah
okay we made a mistake here so this else
was not supposed to be closed here
let's move it ahead
yeah i think
this looks good
let's
write
another code for
another variable
that is website
and do the same thing again
website
now we will check if the url address
syntax is valid or not
so
will just be assembling
you
you
so
now we will write the
test input function as we did
in the form section so let's just
copy it from there since it's going to
be the same
now let's write
the php script
for the form
validation section
on method would be post
action would be
php script again
you
i'll just skip ahead with this part of
the program
so now that we have a complete form here
let's close it
as you can see we have entered full name
email address website comments and
gender parts to the
form
now let's write our final php script to
display the details
since this will also be similar to the
last part
we will just copy it from the
and make the necessary changes
so
[Music]
what we don't have is
full name this would be just name email
now this would be
a website
there's no number
it's deleted
there's a comment and there's a gender
let's close the script
and also close our
webpage
now let's save the file
open a browser and check if our web page
is working correctly
type localhost the name of the folder
and the name of your file
okay
so let's write something mac
mac x y z added now let's not write
something after it so that the email
address would be wrong
just to check
one two three
dot
see
comment
anything would do
gender mail and let's click on submit
so as you can see
it shows enter a valid website url and
the email address is incorrect
let us also check by writing
an incorrect name that would be mac1
email address
mac xyz at the rate and one two three
dot c
now it's showing the error for the name
two
okay let's write something that is
correct
mac
gmail.com
website would be www.simplylearn.com
comment could be anything
mail
and no errors here
as you can see we have got the output
today we are discussing everything about
tread operators in php
let's begin with the definition first
trud stands for create
read
update and delete
these are the four fundamental functions
of persistent storage
these operators are used in creating
user interface conventions that help us
to view
search and modify data via computer
based forms and reports
basically the data is read built updated
and deleted
moving forward let me talk about the
purpose of these operations one by one
with the help of demo codes
but first things first let's create a
database to do that
open xampp control panel and start
apache and mysql
now let's quickly open our web browser
open the localhost and go to phpmyadmin
section
now let's
create a new database and
name it
my bb
let's name the table users and we will
have
six fields in it
first would be id it would be integer
and auto incremented since it would be
the primary key
the second
would be
first name
type back here
let's give it 250
the third would be
last name
variable character
similarly
next would be an email
password
and finally
gender
so now that our table has been created
let's move on to the coding part
now first we are going to create a
file named config.php
to configure
the database
now we will create
variables
and i will explain the use to you
later
this is the
default username for a localhost
now the default password for a database
is empty since there is no password in
our database
and the database name
would be my
db
that's what we have named a database
now let's quickly create the connection
using
pawn variable
my sqli command
server name
username
password
and the database name
now this will create a connection
for our database
and now
let's also
check
for errors while creating the database
now if an error is found while
connecting to the database
it will show a message as connection
field
now let's end the file
and move on to understanding the
different credit operations
now first comes create
so let us also create a new file and
name it
create dot php
now the create procedure adds the insert
statement to create a new record now
let's write the code
for this
now what this line will do is it will
act as a link between the configuration
dot php file
and this create.php
to connect to the database
now
we are checking
if the submit button
on the form is pressed
now when the submit button on the form
will be pressed
the
fields
are required to be sent to the database
for that we first need to create
different variables
similarly
last name
these are the names that we have given
to the
different sections in the table of our
database
password was password
and finally
gender
now let's write the sql query
insert into the name of the table that
is users
and now
we need to name
the
fields we are going to be entering the
details into
since id is auto implemented we are
going to be starting with first name
similarly last name
email
password
and
lastly
gender
now
these are the fields we are going to be
entering data into
now the values
would be
the variables that we just created which
are
getting the data from the form using the
host function
into the variables
so
first name
similarly
last name
email
password
and gender
so
the code
to enter the
values into the database is complete
now let's also execute the query
so
to do that
we will send the query using the connect
and
put the attribute as sql fields
now
if the records are created
it will display a successful message
else
in case of an error
it will
show a error message
now let's
close the connection
close function
and move on
to creating our html form
[Music]
now let's give
a heading here
now this since this is a registration
page let's give the heading sign up form
and create
the form
let's leave the action field as blank
and method
would be since we're using post the
method would be
post
[Music]
[Music]
now i'll just skip ahead with this form
part now as you can see i've completed
the code for the registration form which
will include the first name
last name
password and gender
now let's
save it
and move on to the next part
that is the view procedure
now the view procedure table records
data based on the primary key noted
within the input parameter
now let's create another file
named
view dot php for it and write its code
now i will run
the entire code in a single go and
explain
how these different card operations are
working on the web page
now let's write the query to get the
data from the users table
from
users
now this will
retrieve all the data into from the
table
also let us execute the query
using
connect
query and pass
sql into it
and the php script
and right are
html
code
title would be
view
page
now i'm linking this page to a bootstrap
css document
to make it look
somewhat stylish
since basic html page looks pretty
boring
or to do that we are going to be
using the reference
and i have added the link for the css
file
now let's
complete the
rest of the page
heading to this division
users
now this will also display the id from a
table
so we are going to be creating a
different set of
column
to display the id
similarly
it will be the same
for the
rest of fields so i'll just
copy this
this will be for email
gender
and editor
[Music]
gender
and action
let's close it
so this will check if
there is data present in
our database
now
there is data
we are going to be
fetching the
same data
um
you
similar codes will be written
for the rest of the fields
so we will just
let me
just copy and paste
and change
the details
first name
last name
email
and
gender
you
uh
these are the codes for the edit and
delete commands
and finally
let us
close the page
now let's quickly move on to the
third part
update file
and write its
code
now
when the update button for the form is
clicked
we need
this code to process it
and similarly
for the rest of the fields
let's quickly change
user id
this would be id
last name
last name
all of our
variables are complete now let's write
the query
for the sql
update
name of the
table
users
and set
because
name
is equals to
first name
and similarly
for the rest of the code
now
let's execute the query
pass sql to it
again if
the record is a
successful updation
pass successful message
and
if any error is occurred
we will give an error message for it
now if
id variable set in the url we need
we know that we need to edit a record to
do that
we will
again write a code
using get method
now we will write sql command
to get the data
and
execute a query
you
this is a very similar code to what we
have written earlier
to fetch the data if the number of rows
is greater than zero
okay
now what i am going to do is i am going
to
also skip ahead for the code
for this
update form
now this is the code for the update form
and now
last but not the least
we will
create the file
for delete
and write a code
very similar to how we have written the
rest of the codes
let's write the sql query the same old
routine
so as you guess i'm going to be skipping
ahead with some of the parts some part
of the code
now this is the code for our delete.php
file
and now
we will save all these files
and
go to a browser and try to run
check if they run correct now let's
open the localhost first and go to
phpmyadmin
and open our
users field here
so as you can see i've already created a
record here i'll
create another one to show you how
for that let's go to localhost
demo
and
go to create.php
so second record let's name it mac
x
simply learn
b
now the email would be map x at the rate
password
and
submit new record created successfully
now let's refresh it
and as you can notice we have created
another record here
now
let's go
to localhost again
and
what was our next operation for crud it
was c create
our
read that would be view.php now view.php
displays both of the records that we
have saved
in our database
now
these number differences would be
because i have created and deleted two
more records before recording this part
of the video
now
let's go
to
edit section of any of this record
so
as you may notice it opens the
update.php file
user update form
also the thing to notice is that it
refers to the id that we are updating in
the url itself
now since we clicked on the edit part
of the first field
it is updating the first field itself
now let's update this
miss
xxx
jbc
xyz.com
and update record updated successfully
now let's check the record
and yes the record is updated
now
since we are done with the two parts
create read
and even the third part update cru now
let's move on to the d that is delete
let's go to the delete
for that we would have to
go to the
view.php itself
now let us delete this
second field mac simply learn the macx
addressing lnb.com
delete
now
you may notice the url delete dot php id
4 now id equals 4 is deleted from the
database
let's check
and yes the file from the database has
been deleted
so
this is how we perform our credit
operations with the help of php and
mysql database
in this video we will learn how to
create a registration page using php
html some css and xampp software
then
we will use that data
and store it in a mysql database
so
let us begin and start writing a code
first
now to do that
we need to go to my computer c drive
now zam folder this is the folder where
the xampp software is installed
here
locate to
htdocs and let us now create a folder
for our
tutorial and
name it tutorial
now we'll open this folder in visual
studio code
and start writing a program
so let us create a first file here
and name it
register
dot
html now this will be the html file that
is the whole structure of how a
registration page will look
you
now
registration
page now this will be the title
of a web page
i think that's enough
now let us move on to the
body of the page
now i'm going to write
register
in an h1 point
for the heading
and
now we'll create a form
action would be
the name
register.php
and method
or tree
post
okay so
the first label that i'm going to create
will be for the username
so in a registration form i'm going to
keep it simple i'm just going to include
three categories that would be username
password and a third one would be email
so
to create a label for
username so you always have to keep in
mind whatever name you're giving here or
in the database whichever you write
first
since the name has to match
so i'm giving username the name username
and that's it for a label
now let us create another label
for
before that
input type for this
will be
text
name as we've already written
will be username
please folder with display
username
and i am going to put this field as
required
which means that the
user cannot leave this field empty
second one would be
label for
password
now i am going to give its input type
as
password
and you will know the reason later
you can also give input type for the
password as text but it will not be
secure then
id will be
password
and this is also a required field
now let us move on to
the label
for our last section that will be email
and
give it
input type
email yes and email can be set as an
input type
name
email
placeholder will display
email
and you guessed it right this is also
a required field
i think
this is it for the registration html
now we move on to
creating our
css page in order for this html
structure to look good
well wait a second i left off of a
pretty important section of the
registration form that is the register
button itself
so
let me just
not form
let me just create
the
registration
for registration button
and will be of type submit
and value
displayed would be
registered
now we'll move on to creating the css
file
and
let us create a new file and name it
style.css
so the code for style.css is already
prepared so instead of writing the
entire code line by line i'm just going
to paste it
and
you can see how it works
so this is the css code that will make
a registration form
look a little better
so i have created different sections
for different sections of the
registration form so this will be the
registration from input button
this is for the color of the
submit button
and
the rest of the form as you can see
now in order for the style.css file to
work
we need to link this file
style.css to register.html
now how do we do that we go on to the
register.html
back
and we add
just
one extra line in the head of the
program
so here what we are doing is
we are referencing our style.css page
into this page itself
now that's it
now both of these pages that we've just
created are linked to each other and now
at least a registration form
structure is complete
it does not work yet but it will soon
now before creating the register.php
code
let us first create a database so that
we have some understanding of what is
going on around everything so to create
a database what we need to do is
open xaml
start the apache and mysql server
now go to your browser
and open the localhost
phpmyadmin
now create a new database
let us name it
form
click on create
now let us name our table as users
number of columns would be
four
the first column will be id
which will be auto incremented
second will be username
make sure to use the same name that
we've used in the code
so that
the code does not malfunction
it will be of type
variable character
password
will also be a variable character
email
and now
so as you can see this is the structure
of our
table
of database form
now let us move on to finally writing
the
rest of the code for our registration
form
so now that we have a database complete
let us move on to a back to our code and
create a register.php file
now the first thing that we need to do
while creating the php code is
we need to connect our code with our
database that we just created so this is
why i stopped in between and created a
database so that you need
you understand better how this code is
functioning
now database host
since
we are using sam to locally host a
server
this will be
localhost
a user will be the root user
since we have not set any password on
the database it will be empty
and finally
the name of our database
what did we name a database
it was form
now i will create
a variable con
to
connect
to connect a database
with our code
so we have created host
user
password
and finally
name
now
we have got to add an error message
which will check
if
the database is
connected or not
so
will be
[Music]
error
connecting to the
database
now let us add some code
to check if any variable is
empty or not
okay
now if any of the field is left empty
while filling the registration form it
will display the following message empty
field
now
let us add another
code and check
you
so now that we have added validation
into a code
now what we need to do next is
check
whether the username or the details that
have entered that the user has entered
into the registration form already
exists or not
and if it does
display an error message and if
the details are new enter the details
into a database
now to do that
let us write another if statement
so
now here i am writing
an sql command which will select
id
password from users that is the name of
a table
where username and
here we are going to check if the
username entered still exists or not
look
now if the number of rows is greater
than zero which means username already
exists so we need to display
an error message that would be username
already
exists
try
again
and if it does not
now in this else part we will be writing
the code
for
to send our data into the database
now here
instead of selecting we are going to
insert the data into
users which is a table
and
the fields will be username
password
email
and that's it
now the password variable
is going to fetch
the details
of the password here
and email
add another statement
to
execute
and display
another message now since we have
entered our data into the database we
need to display
a following message too
this would do
now
[Music]
this will display
an error message in case something goes
wrong
and now
since we have completed this part of the
code let us end a statement
close the connection with the database
here and end our php script
so now that our code is complete now let
us run
the code and check if it works fine
so
our apache server is running
let's go back to a browser
open the localhost name of the folder
so as you can see register pages are
visible here
register.html
and create
a user
tony
accurate aaron
you have successfully registered and you
can now login
so
let us now check
if it's visible in our database
so our database is forms
users
and as you can see the
file that we just created tony
is visible here in a database
along with the email and
one thing that you may notice is that
the password is not visible here since
we use the hash protection for passwords
so passwords will not even be visible to
the
database admins
so this is how you create a registration
form with the help of html php exam and
mysql database
in this tutorial we'll create a simple
login system using php and mysql now
this tutorial is comprised of two parts
in the first part we'll create a login
form and in the second part we'll create
a local form also we will show you how
to create a database in order to access
the login web page as well now first
things first let us quickly go to c
zam htdocs and create a folder let's
name it demo and quickly open our visual
studio code now for this tutorial we'll
be creating a set of files for different
functions now there will be six in total
let us first create these files and
we'll write the code later now the first
file would be index.php
now this is the file that will be
responsible for the login page where
we'll enter a username and password to
login now the second file would be
login dot php now this file will be
responsible for how our login system
will work similarly
there will be a logout file that will be
responsible for how our logout function
will work next
would be
home.php now this is the file for our
home page when we login into our account
next would be a file to link our web
page to the database that would be
database connection dot php and finally
we'll add a css file to make the page
look better now let's get on to writing
a code first let's begin with index.php
now in this page we will create
the login page
let's
add the title
as login
now here i am going to link this page to
the css file that we are going to write
later
now in this reference
we will refer it to the style.css file
we created
let's create a form
now since
login.php is responsible for how our
login page will work we will link this
index.php to login.php
method would be
first
let us add a heading
login
now this part of the code will be
checking for error and displaying error
if
something wrong happens
now we will
add our
username and password fields
let's add another label for password
input type would also be password
now let us
add the
login button
it would say
login
and our form here
now our index.php
code is complete now let's move on to
login.php
and write its code
now what we are going to do is we are
going to connect this page with the
database page
now here
we will be validating the data entered
in the form
let us
create a variable
for username and password
make sure not making any spelling
mistakes otherwise
you will run into errors
[Music]
now
what this code is doing
is it's checking if there's an entry
in the username and password field and
if it is empty it will display the
message as username is required
similarly what we're going to do is
we are going to create an elsif
that would check if the password field
is empty
and display an error message
in a similar way
now that is set up let's import our data
from our database now we have not
created the database yet but
we'll write the sql query and we'll
create a database later now what i'm
going to do is i'm going to name my
table as users so here i'm writing
select star from users where
user name
would be
the
value we passed and similarly password
would also be the value that we
passed
now this is where if the password and
username match with what we have in a
database it will display a message as
logged in
now we are going to create a session
that would be a login session
now id will also be a field in a
database that would be auto incremented
and work as the primary key
okay if function is complete
time to write the else part
now the else part would be if the
username or password you have entered
does not match with the one we have in a
database so it would display incorrect
username or password as the error
message
location will be same index.php
so now
we have our login.php file also complete
now let's get on to our home.php file
and quickly
write the code for it
we will start the session
now this
would be our home page
let us also
link it to the
css file
tile dot
css
now
with this php script we will display
the username of the person that's logged
in so suppose my username would be mac
so it would display hello mac we will
very soon see the practical demo for it
too
now we will link this home page with the
logout session that is logout.php
and
end this
okay so home.php is also complete so
next would be to work on the lower part
now this is a very small code since it
is only working to in any session that
has been created
now first unset the
session
and
then
destroy it
now can you guess the location
it would be
index.php now see this is all the code
for the logo file now finally we will
move on to database connection file
where we will connect our entire web
page these entire four files to the
database
so
we are going to create variables for
let us name it since we have already
used unnamed for username now this is
the name for the server and since we are
hosting a server locally it is localhost
now the next variable would be for the
name of the
okay let us let us change the spelling
this would be name of the default
database
[Music]
password would be blank since by default
there is no password and
this is the name of the database that we
are going to keep now
let us keep the name of our database as
test underscore database
now we will pass
the variables
that we just created
now
we will check if the connection that we
have created is
working or not and if not we will
display a message as connection failed
now all of our files are complete the
only thing left is style.css
now since style.css is only for the
looks of the of the webpage and is not a
very necessary file for our login
function
i will just copy paste the code that i
have already written and let us now move
on to creating a database now to do that
first open xampp control panel
and go to your browser and type
okay
localhost go to phpmyadmin
and click on new database now
the name that we wrote for the database
in our code was test underscore db so we
will have to name it the same here too
database has been created the table name
would be users number of columns would
be three the first column would be for
the id and it will be auto incremented
now id will act as also the primary key
for this table second would be
user
name
100 would be okay
and
third would be password now as you can
see our table users has been created
with id username and password now
let us
open
our login page now this is our login
page so to login we first need some
credentials in the database now we don't
have that kind of time to go on and
create a registration page for it too so
let us just manually add one or two
records into the database from here
phpmyadmin itself so now what we are
going to do is we are going to this
insert section
and under the username
let us type mac
and password would be one two three four
five so let's go back to browse and as
you can see we have our credentials here
map password is one two three four five
so
let's add just one other
simply learn its password would be a b c
d e
and
yes so we have both of our credentials
now
now
let's go to the login page and try to
log in with the credentials that we just
created so
okay let us first enter our wrong
password to check if our error messages
are working correctly
yes absolutely so it's showing incorrect
username or password since the password
i entered was incorrect now let us leave
this username blank
enter some random password so it is
showing username is required so our
program is working perfectly now let's
enter the correct credentials
and yes so this is our home page and it
is showing hello with the username that
have logged in mac and now we have got
that logout button which will end this
session and take us back to the login
page now let's try to
log into a second account
and hello simply learn we will learn
what is rest api with php
now let's get started
now suppose you want to create a weather
app for weather forecasts in your area
now to do that you have to set up
supercomputer and a satellite to monitor
the real-time weather
but i wish everyone could be that rich
now for those who cannot afford the
setup you can get the same information
from an existing web service using an
api
now an api acts as a medium between a
web service and your application which
helps you communicate your request with
the service and get a response
so in this video we'll be learning about
what is rest api
principles of rest api
how does a rest api work and finally
creating a sample rest api with the help
of php
now let's move on and see what exactly
is res api
api stands for application programming
interface
now api is a set of protocols which acts
as a medium of communication between
programs
in other words it is a way two programs
talk to each other
now let us understand this with an
example
suppose you
the client go to a restaurant to eat now
here the restaurant is supposed to be
the server
how do you communicate your order to the
kitchen
here the waiter comes in the picture
now here the waiter acts as a medium
between you the client and restaurant
the server to send your request to the
kitchen and get food in return as per
requested
this is exactly what an api does
so now that we have an understanding of
api let us look at what res means in
rest api
now rest stands for representational
state transfer
it is an architectural style which
defines a set of protocols of how an api
is written now
rest follows a set of principles for the
design and development of an api
now it is a very efficient technology as
rest takes less bandwidth over similar
other technologies
so now that we know what res api is let
us move on to understanding the
principles on which a rest api is
designed
now the first principle is client server
the second stateless
third cacheable
fourth uniform interface
fifth layered system and sixth code on
demand
now let us understand these principles
one by one
client server
a res api design works on the concept
that the client and server should be
isolated from one another
and develop independently
this helps in increasing manageability
across various platforms
stateless now according to this
principle res apis should be stateless
which means calls can be made
independent of one another
also every request sent from the client
to the server must include all the info
needed to comprehend the request
cachable
this principle states that a rest api
should be able to hold cacheable data
the data and the response should be
indirectly or directly categorized as
cachable or non-cachable
uniform interface
according to this principle there should
be a uniform interface across all
devices and platforms for the
interaction between application and
server
layered systems now res api's
architecture includes several layers
that operate together to construct a
hierarchy that helps generate a more
scalable and flexible application
due to the rest api layered system the
application has better security as
components in each layer cannot interact
outside the subsequent layer
moreover it balances loads and offers
shared caches for stimulating
scalability
now the last code on demand now this is
optional but this principle allows for
coding to be communicated through the
api as executable code to the client to
be used within the application
we now know on what principles an api is
designed
now let us see how an api work
now res api makes use of http methods to
implement various tasks based on the
client risk request
so the http method uses grid to perform
various operations on the server
grid here stands for create
read
update and delete
now in case of http methods
post method is used to create
get method to read data
put method to update it and delete
method to delete data
so i hope you have some understanding of
what risks apis are
principles on which they are designed
and how do they work
now let us move on to creating a sample
risk api with the help of php
so first let us open the xampp
control panel
and start our apache and mysql servers
now what i am going to do is i am going
to
create
a database
for my api
let us name it api
and let us name the
table as users
it will have four columns
first one would be id
integer and it will be auto incremented
the second let us name it as name
third would be
age
and finally
email
now name would be a text and email will
also be a text
let us quickly save this
and now we have a table for us
now let us add some data into the table
so
mac
it would be 21 email would be mapped mac
xyz.com
now
let us create another entry
name could be simply learn
age
email
simply learn
xyz.com
now as you can see we have added two
rows
with the data that we just entered
now let us move on to the visual studio
code and
see
htdocs
let us create a new folder let's name it
api
and
open with visual studio code
let's create a new file let us name it
tutorial
[Music]
dot php
and now let's start writing our code
now first what i am going to do is i am
going to connect
my database
with this code
now since
the database is locally hosted
it will be local first
root
since there is no password
this field has to be empty
now
what was the name of a database that is
api
that is what we have to enter here
now this is a variable
to get the response from the server
for the database
okay there's something wrong
now it seems like my
opening curly braces key is not working
so i had to open
this on-screen keyboard
we don't need you
right now
now let us create
another variable named sql
now this is select this command will
select
all the data
from our table users
users
again we're going to need the curly
braces
what i am doing here is i am creating a
variable
as a counter and i am going to
give it a value of zero
now let us create a while
loop
and in this while loop
i am going to
fetch the data
and displayed in json format
uh
now we are going to write the names of
all the
rows that we created in a table
i'm just going to
copy paste it otherwise we'll have to
use this on-screen keyboard again and
again
second one was
name
agent email
now what i'm going to do is
i will
plus plus the counter
now to display it as an in json format
we have to write
is an end code
with response
error message and now let us
end the
code
let us go and quickly
save our code
open our browser
go to the localhost api
this is the fold that we created
now as you can see
dot php is visible here and when you
click on it you can see the data from
the database been
extracted
with the help of api in json format
in this video on php web development we
will learn how to create a website with
the help of php
we'll also be using html css bootstrap
and mysql in this tutorial
so get ready to create your very own
website
now before we get started with the
step-by-step tutorial let me give you a
glimpse of the website that i'll be
building in this video
so let me just quickly go to my browser
and type in localhost
followed by the name of the folder where
i have created the website
so i'll be making a photo gallery
website
like this
so in case you're a photographer you can
build a similar website in order to
showcase your talent
and if not you can always create your
own personal website for anything you're
passionate about
so
without any further delay
let's get right on to a tutorial
so first things first let me show you
the environment that we'll be working on
while creating a website
so we are going to be needing
two softwares that is
visual studio code that we'll be using
as our id the code editor
and the second one would be
xampp
now zamp is a web server solution
package which we generally use in order
to manage our database and create a
local web server
you can download it from these
respective websites
since i've already download downloaded
both of these softwares so
we'll be skipping that
now
let us begin
so
after that you've installed both of
these surface just go to your
c drive locate xam folder
and inside the xampp folder look for
htdocs
and inside this htdocs
name a folder you can name it anything
i'll be naming it photo since i'm
creating a website regarding photos
and then right click inside this folder
and click on open the code
so this opens up our visual studio code
and as you can see our photo folder is
visible here
now also one thing that we need to do is
go back to this photo folder
right click
and create two new folders first one
would be css so it's considered a good
practice even if you're using a single
just a single css file it is considered
a good practice to create a separate css
folder inside your project folder
also
create another folder
and name it images so this is where
we'll be keeping all the images for the
website
so let us go back to visual studio code
so as you can see both of these folders
are now visible here
now
go on and click on new file
the first file that we are going to
create is index.php
and inside this index.php will be
writing the code for the main page of a
website
so let us start
first
click on an exclamation mark
and as you can see a block of code
already written is
visible here now
so
we just need to add a few things
first
let us
put the title the title would be
of course
go to
gallery
next up
we need to add a few links to our
webpage in order for it to function well
so
the first link
would be
this is a link to
link this page to
bootstrap
you can also easily find it on the
internet
or you can just
type in from here
let me just go to the browser to check
if this link is working
yeah
seems fine to me
now we are going to add
another
link to it
now this link
will be for the link for a css file that
we'll be creating later on
since we'll be
putting that css file inside a css
folder i am going to link it to
style.css
so that's it
we are done for the first part of a code
now let's
end this head section
and
move on to the body section of our web
page
so inside this body section what we
first need is
to add a few scripts
for our page which will be responsible
for the design of our web page
so
these are the three scripts
that i'll be linking to a web page you
can just
look and write them as it is
also keep
these three scripts at the end of your
body so
any code that will be writing inside
body will be above these three scripts
now let's
design the web page
so the first thing that we'll be needing
is a navigation bar in a web page so let
us quickly go to the browser
so instead of writing an entire big
block of code
we can just copy it from the internet
so
bootstrap provides it
you with many such designs so what we
are going to do is we will type in
navbar
bootstrap
and hit enter
so as you can see
just
scroll down and as you can see this is
the navigation bar
which this code will display
also
there are different navigation bars
according to your need along with the
code
so you can just
copy any of the one you like i'm going
to be copying this one
click on copy
go back to the code and
just paste it
so now what we have here is our
navigation bar ready
so
let us go to the browser and check
how does our web page look
so after the local host what we're going
to do is we will write the name of the
folder in which we are writing a project
which is photo
well there seems to be some
problem since this
nav bar is lacking the css design let us
go back to our code and see
what went wrong
well yes this css file that we linked
here after css there is not a dot but a
slash
i think it should work fine now
well
the problem still persists
let me go back and recheck
well yeah i've made some spelling error
here
this is bootstrap not bot strap
and let us go back
reload
and yes as you can see our navigation
bar is
well and good
let's go back and make some changes to a
navigation bar the first change that i'm
going to be making is i will change the
color theme of the nav bar
to
dark note mark
go back
reload
and looks better
now
here
auto gallery
good
also
since i'll be using the drop down menu
it is absolutely up to you if you want
to use it or not
since i'll be using it
i'll just change the
name
to
categories
and the three
category will be
the first is
nature photo photographs
the second would be
architecture
and the third
would be
travel
so let's go back
refresh categories nature architecture
and travel so this travel looks a little
different from this nature and
architecture
so as you can notice this this line that
is dividing
this section to this section
so
let's go back so
that line
comes from this part of the code so
we'll just copy
and paste it here
looks good
now
that we're back we don't need
this
disabled
and the search bar
so i'll be removing
that
particular part of the quotes
and this form2
go back to the browser refresh
and all of the parts of the
navigation bar that we don't need are
now have now been removed
also this link
would be
for about section of the web page and we
will also add another section or another
link that would redirect us to the
contact part of the web page so
to do that to add another link we will
just copy this code
and paste it
and instead of about
this will be contact
go back
refresh
home contact about categories so this
categories should come before
these two
so
what we're going to do is we will just
copy this section of the code
and put it after the drop down menu
right
now go back
refresh
until we copied it instead of
cutting it
so
it's now visible twice
reload
home categories contact and above
looks perfect
so you see now that's the beauty of
building a website you don't have to
write the entire code by yourself
there are
codes already written for all these
kinds of stuff this navigation bar the
carousel that i'm going to be using in
the website the blocks of photos that we
are going to display
on the web page and a lot of design
templates you can call them have already
been written for you to use them instead
of wasting your time and writing the
entire
long blocks of code
now next up what i'm going to do is i'll
just go back
to our
photo folder
and inside this
images
i'll just
copy the images that have already
downloaded
copy
go
back
images
and paste it here
so now that we have our photos inside
the images folder
let's go back to our code and
write
a
carousel code or just copy it from the
bootstrap
go back to bootstrap
here
look for carousel
so as you can see
this is what a carousel looks like so a
big
photo
in
on the front of your webpage as you
already saw when i showed you the
website
these are the different types of
carousels available on the bootstrap
website
you can use any of them
so
the first one is just a single photo
second one
is slides of photos third is slides
photos with this marking
and the final one would be all of them
combined with captions so of course
we'll be using the final one
so copy the code for the final
carousel or whichever one you like and
go back to your code
and here
after this navigation bar
paste your calendar code
click on save
go back
and refresh
so since we haven't added any images
here
there are none visible but you can see
this
carousel has been added to our webpage
so
let's go back and now we are going to
add the images that we just
pasted in this images folder
so in this carousel
code look
for
image src so this is the location
of the image that will be displayed
so
type in images that is the name of the
folder from where you will be picking up
the images
for slash and
let me just
go back to this images architecture for
yep
so architecture 4
in this alt
type in
architecture and here
is the heading so this is part of the
caption of the
carousel so
i'll be writing arcade texture
here and i'll make this heading a little
bigger
it's three i think h3 would do
and i don't want to add any more
descriptions
if you do you can write all of that
inside this paragraph
but
i won't be so i'll just remove it from
here
i'll do the similar
with
this
so
what we're going to do is we will write
images
slash
and go back
what image i'm going to be adding nature
4 would do
nature
or
type in
nature
similar
to what we did
above
h3
h3
remove this
and now
here the last one would be travel
h3
h3
and
let me just
type in the
travel 5
travel
5
and in this alt
type
travel
and we are good to go
okay let's reload
and voila so our
images are visible here with this
beautiful carousel
and you can forward them and
well
does this not look beautiful to you
so architecture
nature and travel
but
as you can see we have some problem here
the images are way too big to fit on
this part of the screen
and it's going all the way down
and this part of the carousel is not
visible on the main page when someone
opens the website which absolutely does
not look good
so
what we're going to do for it
now to fix this what we're going to do
is we will go back to our code editor
inside the css folder
we will create the file that we linked
at the start
of our tutorial style.css
and
here
just
write this code
margin
zero
adding also zero
and
box sizing
would be border box
so
now to display the images
on the
just on the main page of our website
what we're going to do is we will
put a dot go back to the
main index.php and from here
copy this
name of the class carousel item
go back to style.css
paste it here carousel item and type ing
and inside this
we will define the width
and the height of the image so the width
would be 100
and we are going to keep the height at
95
we h so that it does not go beyond the
webpage
let us quickly save it
go back
reload
and yes
it looks great
and
it's also visible on our screen now
now next up what we're going to do is we
will be creating different sections on
this very
webpage
for
the different categories that is nature
architecture and travel
so
go back to the code
under this
carousel code
let us start writing our first section
that would be
section
class
so
i'll be using
my four and by four
the first
depth
so what we want is we want the text to
be in the center of the page so
the class would be text center
and
the first category is nature
now the next thing that we need to do is
we need to add the images to it
so how do we do that
also we are
not to display a single image
on
on the entire webpage what we need is we
need to display small
three blocks of images in a row
so
we
need to create another div
class
and inside the class
we will define the column
for large
systems
for the
mid ones
and
for the mobile devices
so
after you've written this class after
you've written this div
the images
doesn't matter the size of the screen
only
three images will be displayed on a
large and middle screen and a single
image will be dis visible when open on a
mobile phone so
all in all your website would be very
responsive to all the devices that you
will be using
let's just close it and inside this tip
what we're going to do is
we will link our image
and
the image
would be
since this is nature
let's use nature1
which image would give we have already
used in the carousel
nature four
so let's skip that
and
put the class as
fluid
and padding
bottom padding would be three
well i think
it's
done
so this is the
first section let's go to our page
refresh
so nature and our first image is also
visible here so what we need is we need
to display two more images in this row
go back
and it's now all copy and paste
just
not this part
this part of code
copy
paste
and paste
so
now
nature 2
and nature 3.
go back
refresh
okay there seems to be a problem here
let us figure out why this is happening
okay we forgot to add the
road if
and without the road if the images will
not be displayed in a row
but of this
so
container
fluid
i'm using this
since
just a second
let me paste it here
yeah
and
we will create another div
named row
and
our entire code
will go inside it
and we'll paste it
let's go back and check if it changes
anything
and it does
so our images are displayed perfectly
our first section that is nature for our
categories is complete now
now next what we need to do is
i think you guessed it we just need to
copy this section
and paste it
twice
since there are two more sections
so after the first section
in the second one would be
for
architecture
the images we need to change
architecture 1
architecture 2
and
architecture three
yeah
refresh
nature architecture
and well nature again because we did not
edit the third part of the code
so the third part of the code
will be for
travel
let us quickly
add the images
so travel to
travel four
and i
think we use travel
5 already
so
travel 6
and go back
refresh
and travel images architecture and
nature so
half of our website is
already done guys
now
what we need to do is we need to create
two more sections for the contact and
about
so
for the contact part of the webpage
we'll be needing a form that we will
then go on and
link to a database that will be creating
later on
and the about section will be
responsible to
give
some information regarding the website
regarding the photographer that have
uploaded the images
so
let's go back to our code and
move on to creating another section for
the
contact
so
wait let me just copy only this section
of the code
and of course
we'll be needing a closing tag
this will be
contact
us
and
let's
create another div
class would be
50
and m
auto so
why i'm doing this is because
inside the contact will be creating a
form
where there will be columns
and to manage the width and margin of
these columns i am writing the class for
it
inside this tip
we will write a form
inside the form the first thing that we
need is action
and the action for the form
will be
about
dot php this is a file that will be
creating later on
and the next thing is method
which will be post
let's close this
create another div
class
named form
group
okay
from group
close it
inside this
i'll write a label
that would be
name
this will be our first column input
type
text of course
let's give it a name so this is very
important so the name that you're going
to write here
should be
matching should be matching with the
name in the database
and class
from
control
now
just copy this
test
and
paste
so the second section would be for
email
type will also be
email
name will also be
email
third would be for the number
let us keep the type text in case
someone wants to enter the
sud codes
and let's go back
refresh
contact us the fields are visible now
what we need is a submit button
so after this step
let me
create a button
type
submit
class
so this
will make the button look
green adding some
css
and
the button would be called submit
go back
refresh
submit button is here
now
let us also create a section for the
about part of the page and then we'll
move on to
making our database
so to do that what we need to do is
we'll just copy this section
for the about
paste it here
close the section
and here
let's
start writing the code
the class container
fluid so
why are we using this container fluid
class is because sometimes when you
don't use this class
the images or text from your web page
tends to
create
so you can see a scroll bar here
vertically it tends to create another
scroll bar
horizontally which we don't want
so container fluid
close the step
inside it
let me create a class
text
center
it will say the name mac
we just kept some space
and
write a paragraph
with a class of course
text
center
otherwise if the text will start from
the extreme left it would look weird
and
close it
let's add some bold
and right
let's see
i am a
passionate
photographer
interested
in
working
architecture
nature and
travel
photography
next would be
um
a
full-time
freelancer
with an
experience of
five
yes
well i think this would do
refresh
oh we did not change this we'll just get
right on to it
contact us i'm a passionate photographer
interested in working architecture
nature travel photography
freelancer and all of the things that we
just written about mac
we just need to change this
to
[Music]
about
and i think we're done
yes
so
our web page is almost complete guys
now we need to do some
changes
or add some things so the first thing
that we'll be adding is
and about dot php file
and inside this about.php file we will
be creating a connection with our
database and fetching the data from it
or sending the data from our form to the
database
so before that
let's go back
to the browser type in localhost
followed by php
my admin
click enter
but before that
you must
open xampp control panel and start the
apache server and mysql server since i
already did i did not show you the steps
so after the my sequel server has been
started you can see this php myadmin
panel and from here we can create
databases
so inside this phpmyadmin
click on new
and let us name our database as
graphy click on create
now what we are going to do is we will
create a table
where the data
will be stored from our form
let us name the table as users number of
columns would be four
the first column would be
course id
which will be auto incremented
the second column would be name
type variable character
250
third is
email
also
variable character 250
and the final was our number
variable character
250
and
click on save
so as you can see the structure of our
table
the table users have been created inside
the database photography
now
we need to go back to our code
and write the code php code to connect
our form
to this database
so first variable that i'll be creating
is
gone to connect
the database
since a server is locally hosted the
name of the server would be
localhost
root
that is the default
now if
connection
so this
if condition will check if the
connection is successful or not and if
successful display
connection
successful
next
also
add if the connection is not successful
we should always have an error message
connection
failed
next what we need to do is we need to
mysql i
select
underscore
bb
and inside this
we need to mention the name of our
database which is
let's just go back and recheck
photography
because the name is
very important if you
mess with the name the entire code goes
to win
now
let me create some variables which will
fetch
the data
from the form
in order to send them to the database
so
let's keep the same names
so that we don't
create any confusion
email and of course
number
post
so now that we have our variables we
need to run a
query
so
since we are fetching the data from the
form and inserting it into a table we
need to run a query for insert
into the name of the table that is users
and then
name
email
number
followed by the values that
we'll be
giving them
so
notice this is the
name of the
fields that you've given in your table
and
this
these values are these variables that
we've just created
so
inside it
name
second would be
email
and third would be
number
i think the query is done
now
to check if
it works
we will run another query
and i am going to add a header file here
because once you click on submit button
let me just go back
so if you click on submit button here
the page will redirect
to a different page which will just
display connection successful we don't
need that we need to stay on this page
itself so in order to do that
i am writing this header file
with the location
of
index.php
enter
and
i think we are done here
now
let's go back
and
add some details mac
mac after it
simply
learn.com
number would be one two three four five
six seven eight nine
zero
click on submit
go back to your database
click on browse
and if the connection would be
successful you can see the
data here
and we can
mac
email and number that's great so
now let's move on to the final section
of the website
so
how do we make this categories
nav bar work
well it's pretty simple we just need to
redirect to a section
of a web page whenever clicked a button
so when we click on nature we need a web
page to be redirected to this section
so
let's just go back to our code
and what we're going to be doing is we
will
create
links
just a second
for every section of our webpage
so let's go back to the first section
that is
nature
and here
right
give it an id
so the id for this section
would be
nature
close the tag
cut
and
paste it here so as you can see
this id
this section of our web page is enclosed
in this id so now with this a tag we can
refer
our this section of the web page
to any button
similarly
we will add
another id here
so the id would be
architecture of course
make sure the spellings are correct
put it after the section
now
go back a id
this would be
travel
okay
just
a second
cut it
paste it here
again
what i'm going to do is instead of
writing it again and again
i'll just copy it from here
paste
it since this is
contact us
let me just put
contact
contact here
and the section
right
and
this will be
of course
about
yes
good now what we need to do is we need
to refer these sections with the
respective ids to the buttons
go back to the navbar code on your
webpage
so here is a navbar code so inside it
you can see after every button there's a
reference you just need to
add the name of your id
do not remove this
and
architecture
travel
contact
and
about let's go back
refresh
click on categories
okay
what happened here okay no
nature
yep
travel
yep
contact
about so everything works perfectly now
so while we're added let me just okay
let me first show you
rob
probably
start dot com one two three four five
five five five five
click on submit
so as you can see whenever you click on
submit
it redirects you to the front of the
webpage
i don't want that
yeah the database is working so
just go back
to the about.php
and here we added the header location
index.php so it is redirecting
the
code to the start of the webpage
what we need to do is we need to
redirect it to a particular section that
is contact so just add
contact in front of it
save
go back
scroll down
tony
tony
stock
industries dot com
one two three seven seven seven seven
seven seven
click on submit
and as you can see after you click on
submit the page does not go back to the
starting it just stays here while the
data
has been submitted
to our database
now that we have completed our website a
quick question for you guys
if you were asked to create a website
based on your interest
what would the website be about
let us know in the comment section below
now let me show you a glimpse of the
website we'll be creating which is
called techbyte.com
but you can obviously create a website
for the product of your choice
so let me just go to the browser
type
localhost website and this is the
website that we'll be creating this is a
very basic website for e-commerce
services but as you can see we have
displayed the top products on the front
page of a website and here from the drop
down menu you can see laptops
and phones
so without wasting much time let's get
started
now before we begin let me tell you that
we'll be using visual studio code as the
ide our code editor
and
zam as the web server solutions package
which will be hosting a local server
server for the website
now another thing that we need to do
before beginning
is we need to go to a browser
and type in
bootstrap download
go to this website
and from here
download the bootstrap
file
this will be a compressed file you can
download it from here and i'll tell you
later what we're going to do with it
now let's go and set up a coding
environment
so let me just close this
go to see
exam folder
locate htdocs folder in it and
create
any name for your project
i'll be writing website
and inside this website what you're
going to do is
go to your downloads
now this bootstrap folder that we just
downloaded we are going to extract it
inside
that
website folder
so
let's just go back
so
we
need them outside
delete this
so as you can see we have got a css and
js folder
and we'll be using this in a website
now
let us begin
our code
so right click
open with code
now this is our visual studio code and
as you can see
our website folder is visible here and
from here we can create a new file
so our first file would be
index dot php
now let's start our code
type in exclamation mark
and hit enter and you can see
this block of code
will be visible here
now we need to add a few things
well not a few quite a lot
first would be
title
the title would be well
since my website is take by i'm going to
give the title a stick by
next what we're going to do is we are
going to add
some links
to this index.php
so these are the links for the css files
present inside this folder that we just
downloaded from bootstrap
and we'll be linking some of the files
from this folder
onto our website so that the website
looks
good yeah
now the reference would be
css this is the folder and
the file is bootstrap
dot
min.css
so this is the first file that we're
going to be linking
next
let's add
a script here
so this is a pretty popular script and
you can find it on the internet easily
checks
well yeah
this ends a script here
let me just recheck if i typed
it correctly
yeah seems fine
now moving on
we are going to be adding another script
that would be
javascript
and it will include boots
jquery
sorry bootstrap
i'm just going to find it bootstrap
dot men dot js
here this ends a second script
now
let us just
end
this title
and move on to the
body part of the
code
now
what do we need to produce or create
first
now the first thing that we need is a
navigation bar
so
to create a navigation bar i'll give you
a pretty easy way to do that instead of
writing a hefty big code you need to go
to your browser
since we are using bootstrap why not
take the best out of it
now type in bootstrap
navbar
go to this link navbar bootstrap
and as you can see this bootstrap
this navbar can be
accessed using this code
just copy it go back and paste it in
your body
now we'll be making a few changes to a
navigation bar according to our
e-commerce website but before that
we need to check if this navigation bar
is visible correctly
on the web page now to do that
first
let's open a zam control panel
start our apache server
and go to a browser
now to see the result of your code to
see if this code that you've just
written
is how does it look on a web page we
need to type in localhost followed by
the name of the folder that you created
for your project since the name of my
folder is website i've written website
here click on enter
and well our navigation bar looks a bit
weird
there's no designing to it now let me go
back to
the code and see what i did wrong
well yeah
we don't need this bootstrap
reboot.min.css instead
we need
just bootstrap.min.css
let's
save it go back and reload
well our navigation bar is visible
let's go back to the code
and start making some for changes
the first change that i'm going to be
making is
i will change the
color theme of this navigation bar
and
yeah looks much better
now let me remove
some things
first
let's change the name to
techbuyer.com
well
second
let us let it be home
so this is the drop down i will be
changing it to products
the first product is
laptop
the second one
once
we don't need this here
and
let me put the divider
in between
we don't need this
disabled part
either
and
neither do we need the search form
now i want to make a few changes to the
navigation bar
so this navigation bar seems a little
thin
let me add
just a little bit of breath to it
yep
looks good
and as you can see
laptops phones and this dividing line
now what we need to do create a front
page that is the top featured content on
the front page that will be visible on
our e-commerce website so to do that
create a div class
let us name it
and
this will be a column
div inside this
another div class
this will be for the row
and
now
just a second
yes
this will also need a class since we
want our
text
in the center of the page
and
top
products
okay
let me
just add some spaces
well
before adding those
images and the products onto a page we
need to prepare a little bit more so
before that let us just save this piece
of code and
see how does it look so it displays top
products in the center of the page
looks great
now
what we need to do before we can display
the products on this page is we need to
create a database in where
we are going to store all the
information regarding our products
and we will fetch that data from the
database and display it on our website
now to create the database just go back
to the xampp control panel and start the
mysql server too
now
here
type in localhost
php
my admin
and you can see you
are now redirected to the php my admin
control panel
where you can create different databases
so as you can see i've already created a
database named tech by
under which i have got
another table that is products
with some data here
now
i'll show you how to create a database
from scratch
now to do that we need to go to this new
part
now since we already have a text by
database let us name it something
different e-commerce
and
create
now
we have created a database named
e-commerce and inside the e-commerce
what we need to do is we need to create
a table
let us create the table and name it
products
now our table with will mainly consist
of around
six or seven
columns and let us keep it seven
the first would be id of course and it
will be auto incremented
the second
title of the product
which will be a variable character
255
price of the product
since
prices can be
in decimal
let us keep this decimal
and
the values would be 10 comma 2
next is brand name
this is variable character
100 would do
image now this
column here will contain the location of
the image on our server or
on a system since our system is the
local server
so
this will also be a variable
characteristic
next would be description
this will be a text since a description
can be long
and last could be featured
all right
let us save this table
and we have a products table here
in our new database that is e-commerce
now we need some images for this
image file for our products
now already downloaded some images
let me just
copy them
now go back to a c drive exam
what we're going to do is we're going
back to our website folder
and
we'll be creating a new folder inside
the website folder
and let us name it images
and paste your
images here
let me go back to
this visual studio code and as you can
see
our images are visible here
we'll be using them very soon
let us go back to
this
and let me add an entry here
so we'll be working
with one product and once you understand
the concept you can add many more
products later on so
the title would be
google
pixel 5
the price
65000
brand name goes google
image
now to add the path of your image what
you need to do is you need to go back
here
images now the path would be inside
website
and inside images folder so
website
images
and then followed by the name of the
image since the name for my
google phone is g pixel
i'll be writing
g
pixel dot png
make sure you do not make a mistake by
writing a name
and in the description
well i've copied some description from
the internet i will be posting
the same here
google pixel 5 5g hdb ram 128 gb
space now
inside the featured part
we'll be numbering it one and click on
go so go back to browse
and you can see
your field that you just created visible
here
so now that we have the entry
for our image for our product that is
google pixel 5 phone in our database let
us go back to the code to see how to
retrieve this
information from this database into a
code and display it on our screen
let's go back to our code
and in our code
let's go back to the top
and here
we are going to be creating a php
script
and inside that script
i will be
accessing the database
now
let us create a connection to the
database using mysqli
connect
and inside this what we are going to do
is we will be writing the name of
loop the server since the server is
localhost
and then
this
next would be root
now
again
mysqli
now here select
db database
and inside this
we'll be selecting a database from
the my admin panel
so what we need to do is we need to
write the variable name followed by the
name of the database that we need
information from so our the name of our
database
was
e-commerce
yep
so
e-commerce
so here we have created a connection
with the database now let us create
another file sql
so
for this this variable will be accessing
all the information stored in our table
products
so
we'll be writing some
sql commands
select star that is all the details from
name of our table
products let me just recheck
products yep
and
the
featured
is equals to 1
so remember that
while
creating a
entry we put this featured value as 1
so
this part of the code is done now
let us go back down
where we stopped last
and
our
php
script
so
here
what we are going to do is we will be
creating a while loop
now inside the while loop
we will create another
variable as products
which will be equals to
my sqli
and this function is used to fetch
the data from the database
and
feature
well there's something that we missed we
did not create the variable featured
here
and
well it would have given an error
so
what featured would do is featured would
use the connection to query
the
sql command
now
go back
here
what this while loop will be doing is
this while loop
will be fetching
the data
from our table under the category of
featured number one
so
next what we're going to do is next we
will create another
div class
which would be
inside this h4
another
php
script
is equals to product
now
inside this
we are since this will be the title we
will be displaying the title from here
so what we need to do is
we need to add the title
and
close the
php script here
next
we need to display the image
so
here in this
image src we don't need to write the
path of the image since we have already
entered that into the database what we
need to do is we need to specify
the path
from where we need to fetch the image
from the database so
it's pretty simple
again the same thing
product
and as you
would have guessed it
it will
be
image was it image or images
let me just recheck
it was image
close this close the file
and
here we have retrieved our image
now
protect
inside this product what we are going to
get is
the price
title so that if one would hover over
here it will display the title of the
product
and
that's it
we need to close it
sec
okay
so
yeah
looks good
next
we will display the price of the product
to do that
we will create a class
let us name it
price
close it
rupees
we're doing it again
product
and
here
what we need to do is we need to get the
price
and close this
similarly
whatever details that we need to display
here from the database we are going to
be accessing them
through
this script
with changing the name of the column
that we need to access
so
now that we have all this
let us
also
create a reference page
and
i'll be creating another file
details.php which will display the
details of the product
but
before that let me create a button
type button
class
button success
now the name of the button would be more
and
well
this ends here
also what we need to do is we need to
let me
just see what we need to do is we need
to
end this
while loop
and while
here
and
just
close it
so
this
div
and this div
everything's good
save
let's go back
and see
if it's working
and voila
we have our first product displayed here
on the front page of our ecommerce
website google pixel 5 the phone the
more button does not work yet
but we'll be working on it but
it feels good doesn't it
now let us go back to the code
and
see
how to create this details.php file
first
details.php and inside this file what
we're going to do is we are going to
just copy paste some part of the code
here
and
also
this part of the code
okay
and
we don't need it
now we need
one or two more things to be displayed
here so
just copy this
paste it
and paste it again let's go back to
[Music]
our localhost and what we need to
display here
is
so we have already displayed the title
the price
and the image
so the things that we're left with is
the description
and the brand name
so let's go back
price is already here
just add description
and
brand name
was it brand name
yep brand name
description
it's good
change
class name here
okay
so
what we're going to do is we will be
refreshing this page and clicking on
more
and
well yes good the details of our product
are visible here
now let's go back and
make a little changes
so the first change would be
this so
this would be
product
details
and
save
click
on this still a big gap
yes looks better
now
let me just
you can add some
bold or
italics
or whatever you like
in this code
um what did i do what did i do
so i've added bold in the title
let's see if it works
i'm not sure if it does
okay since it's already a heading
my bad
let me
add it here
okay
save it so this is the price
and yes price is in bold now so you can
make a few changes so look make
your description look better
and let us go back to the main page and
what we are going to do is we are going
to
create two new files for this laptops
and phones to display them separately
when we click on any drop down menu
since they don't work yet
now let me show you an example to create
a file for this product laptops
and
you can create
the rest yourself so
first thing that we need to do is we
need to go back to this database
into a table and
create another entry
so the title would be
a source row
laptop
price would be
1 lakh 20 000 brand name asus
image so the image is website
images
and the name of the image is
rogue asus
dot png
wrote asus dot png
and
i've copied some description for the
from the internet
and
now on the one thing that you need to
notice is we are going to be
keeping this featured part as
2 instead of 1
and go back to browse and you can see
the detail that we just created with the
feature number two so now go back to our
code
and create another file let us name it
product
laptops dot php
let me just see
yep
i have
so
yeah i may have skipped this part so in
the drop down menu when we created a
navigation bar here it was written
this
so we need to replace this reference
with the name of the
php file that we just created that is
product
dash
laptops.php so
protect dash laptops dot php
and inside this
first thing that we need to do is copy
this code paste it here
now here change it to
two
and
drop down
top products everything looks
fine
save it
since the feature number will be two
let us go back
refresh
click on laptops
and here you can see the asus rogue
laptop
visible
now let me
add another product on our feature page
that is a front page to show you how do
we display more than one product with
the same code so
go back to this database and create
another entry
let's say
hp
laptop
price would be
80 000
okay i think i just
created an entry
let me delete it
go back
hp laptop
price
80 000
brand name hp
image website
images
name of the image
that is hp underscore laptop dot png
hp underscore laptop dot png
and the description which i have copied
from the internet
and in this feature we're going to be
writing one
since we are displaying this on the
front page
of our website
go back to browse here are the details
now
let's get back
we don't need to change anything just
save it
go back
and refresh
and as you can see we have our hp laptop
visible here and similarly
we can just re add products into a
database and this single piece of code
is enough to display them all
on our web page
so guys these are some of the basics of
an e-commerce website you can add more
products choices more detailed
descriptions and add more designing
using css bootstrap cards
and
buy sell
sections on your website
just play along with the code and start
making your own web pages in this video
we'll discuss some of the frequently
asked questions in php interviews
now the questions are
categorized in two sections beginner and
advanced questions so without any
further ado let us get started with the
beginner questions
now the most basic question
is what is php
so php stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into html and is
generally used for dynamic web
development
php is also a very compatible language
that is it also works efficiently with
almost 20 different databases such as
mysql post resequal etc
next question what is a session in php
now sessions in php are used to store
data for users under a unique id which
can be then used across multiple web
pages of a website
next what is peer in php now peer
stands for php extension and application
repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of php containing code
snippets and libraries
next
is php considered a case sensitive
language so this is a very often asked
questions in interviews so php is
partially case sensitive since
variables in php are case sensitive
while functions and user defined
functions are not
next
name
different types of data types in php
so different data types in php include
integer float
string
boolean
array
object
null and finally resource so there are
total eight different data types that
exist in php
next question
how is echo different from print
now echo it can output multiple strings
at a time while in case of print it can
output only a single string
now echo does not have a return value
while print always returns one
that is the reason that is echo is
faster because it does not have to
return a value
while it is print is slower in
comparison to echo because it always
returns a value
now
as you can see
both of these commands echo and print
are used in the exact same way
next
what are the rules for naming a variable
now there are certain rules which you
have to follow or certain
good coding practices which you have to
follow while naming a variable in your
php code so variable name must always
begin with underscore or a letter so it
cannot begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so
suppose you want to name your variable
number 1 to 3 so you can use this
variable but you cannot use number at
the read one two three since special
characters are not included
next a variable in php is declared using
this dollar sign followed by the
variable name now as you can see this is
how we declare a variable dollar my
underscore variable you can also put a
number in between or at the end while
naming a variable just not at the start
next
name some popular php frameworks so some
of the popular php frameworks include
symphony codeigniter cake.php and
laravel
moving on
how to check if a defined variable is
null or not
so is a thank function is used to check
if the defined variable has any value or
not so to use this suppose you have this
block of code in front of you so suppose
you want to check if this x variable
that you've defined is null or not so
what you do is you put the is it
function inside the if condition and it
will return true
if it's
not null
while it will return false
if it is a null value since it is not
null it returns true and we can
display echo as variable x is not null
while in the case of variable y it is a
null value syn so
the if condition will be false and it
will not display anything
next
how are objects in php passed so objects
in php are always passed by value not by
reference
next question
how to display output directly to the
browser now
in cases you want to display your output
directly onto the browser while
running a piece of code
you can use it use
these special tags
to display an output directly to the
browser now as you may notice
these tags does not contain the php
written you can use them directly and
replace php with an equal to sign
followed by what you want to display and
end it with a question mark and a
closing bracket
moving on
what is defined function used for in php
now define is used to declare a constant
in php also in contrast to the variables
there is no need for a dollar sign
before declaring a constant since the
value of a constant does not change
this is how you can use the defined
function to declare a constant suppose
you want to declare the value of pi as
3.14 throughout your php code
and
which cannot be changed so we can use
define for that next question is related
to this question since
what is constant functioning used for in
php then so constant function returns
the value of a constant it is not used
to define a constant but it returns the
value of a constant so
suppose you define a function constant
using this defined function and you want
to return this value
you can use this constant function for
that
next
is multiple inheritance supported in php
so php only supports single level
inheritance which means a class can be
extended from only one class using the
keyword extended
next
what are the different types of loops in
php so php consists of a while loop
a do while loop a for loop and finally a
for each loop so php consists of total
for loops
next question
how to concatenate two strings in php
now
two strings can be easily concatenated
using the dot operator in php now to do
that i'll show you with the help of a
code suppose you want to concatenate or
join these two strings str1 hello guys
and the second string would be and
welcome to simply learn and want to
display these strings together so to do
that you
need to use this dot operator in echo as
you can see
this dot operator so first you write
this name of the first string then
followed by the dot operator i've given
this space
and then the next order operator because
this is also going to considered as a
string and then the third string
variable
and this is how you concatenate two
strings
next question what is the use of
function num ar argument
now this function as you can see
is used to return the number of
arguments passed in a function so
suppose you pass a certain number of
arguments in a function and want to know
how many
values or arguments for past
you can use this function for that so
suppose
in this
sample code you want to know how many
arguments were passed
in this
sample function so to do that we declare
a variable number of arguments and we
will equal it to the function of number
function number argument now we will
display it
and this sample has passed three
arguments so the output would be three
moving on
what are super global variables in php
now some predefined variables in php are
known as super global variables because
they are always accessible from any
function file or class regardless of the
score so in all in all they are globally
accessible
so suppose you write a piece of code and
you declare a variable inside it it
would be a local variable and could be
accessed only in that part of the code
but in case of super global variable
they are accessible throughout the
entire code
they include
global server requests posts get files
enb cookie and session
moving on
how to invoke single line and multi-line
comments now a single line comment in
php can be made using this hash followed
by the comment or
double slash followed by the comment
while in case of multi-line comments you
can use this hash star and write your
comments in multiple lines and enclose
it with a star and
slash
what i'm going to do now is i am going
to show you
the
use of these comments in actual vs code
now let us take this block of code for
example now suppose you want to add a
com single line comment after this
variable
so what you will do is
you can use this double slash
this
is
a
variable
also you can use
slash
this is also a
variable so this is a single line
comment now if you try to write
something else
after this in the next line it will take
it as part of the code not part of the
comment
so what do you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose
you need to write two three lines about
this
line of code what you will do is you
will use a slash
star
now write the comment
this
is
displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment
which you can end simply
by star and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments
now let's move on to the next question
that is name some common applications of
php so some of the
most commonly used php applications are
system functions
firm handling so php is very commonly
used to handle the forms that you see on
the web pages
cred tasks now credit tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and php is used very commonly in
that next accessing cookies variables
and set keys
and finally data encryption php provides
security through some of its frameworks
which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites
so now that we have gone through the
beginner level questions that are
frequently asked in php interviews let
us now move on to the advanced level
questions
so
the first question would be how can you
execute a php script from the command
line
now a php script from a command line can
be executed by by opening the command
line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the php file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a php underscore
script.php
so you type in the name
of the php script that you want to run
and that particular php script will be
executed
next
differentiate between a dollar variable
and double dollar variable so
what is the difference between the two
now in case of a single dollar variable
is it is a simple variable that is
simply used to store data so as we
discussed earlier
it is a variable that we defined to
store different data types that is
integer float strings etc
while
a double dollar variable is a reference
variable of variable so
this is used to reference already
existing variables
now to use
or to understand how these two work
you can see this particular block of
code here now in this code what you need
to focus on is this is a simple variable
hello which contains the string welcome
to simplylearn and we have defined
another variable as well
which contains a string hello now in
this echo as you can notice what we are
doing is we are using this
also before that you need to notice is
this is
the same string as the name of this
variable so first we are displaying this
variable
and then we are referencing this
variable here
so what it is doing is it is referencing
the value to another variable so hello
variable is being referenced so
when you execute this block of php
script what you get the output is hello
since this is the variable hello and
after that what you'll
get is welcome to simply learn since
this variable is a reference to this
variable
next
differentiate between get and post
method
now
get method is used to submit form data
while post method is also used for the
same
feature
so the difference between them is get
method sends data as part of php page
url
sorry web page url while a post method
sends data through http header
in get the data since the data has been
sent through the url it is displayed in
the url of the webpage so it is not
secure
while in case of post method it is a
secure form of
data transfer
hence
when developing a website for some
security purposes
usually we prefer post method
next up how to connect to a database
using a php script
now suppose
if you
are asked this question in an interview
what you need to do is you need to just
write this block of code and explain it
to the interview
now suppose we have a php script
and we want to connect it to a database
what we need to do is we will create
three different
variables that is server name username
and password now
what we're going to do is we will create
another variable con that will be used
to connect it and then we'll use the
mysqli functions which will then
pass these variables to create a
connection so these variable values are
localhost username password these are
the default values now to check if the
connection is connected
what we're going to do is we will
use an if condition
if the con variable
gets and connect error we will display a
error message that is connection field
if not we will display connected
successfully
now as you can see here
these names can be the name of the
server that you're trying to connect i
have used localhost username password
for the default values you can use the
name of the database that you're trying
to connect your php script too
next up
what does final class and final method
mean in php
now a final class in php means that the
class cannot be extended
while a final method means that it
cannot be overridden
now as you can see in this block of code
we have used the final keyword for a
class and the final keyword for a
function
now suppose you this final class is
being inherited by this child class what
the program will return is an error
because once you use this final keyword
this class cannot be inherited and
similarly
suppose this function is trying to be
overridden
by this part of the code
it cannot be because we have used the
final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding
now function overloading the same
function is used for different purposes
based on the number of arguments inside
the function while in case of function
overriding
the same name and same argument function
is used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method now let me show you
and demonstrate the difference with an
example
so
let us look at this code so suppose you
have a function named show title
which does have contain a single
parameter and displays when called upon
using this parameter displays function1
now if you want to use the same
name of the function for a different
purpose what you can do is you can
increase or change the number of
parameters inside the function that is
it now contains two parameters so when
the same function is called using two
parameters it will function differently
and display function overloading so this
is how function overloading works next
from this piece of code we can
understand function overriding suppose
you display a function demo in a base
class and you want to override this demo
function inside the
derived class so what you do is you make
another function with the same name
inside the derived class with some
different properties as you can see it
displays something different
now you create an object for the base
class and when you use this base class
object to call this demo function
you can use the properties of this
function here while if you create
another object that is object 2 for the
derived class and you use this object to
call upon the same demo function you are
overriding this base class demo function
that was inherited instead what it will
use is it will use the properties of the
derived demo function so that is how you
overload or override a class function in
php now let's move on to the next
question that is differentiate between
equal to equal to and triple equal
operator
so a double equal operator is generally
used to check if the value of two
operands are equal or not it is
generally used in case of conditional
statements
while
a triple equals to operator performs a
typesafe comparison which means that
will that it will only return true if
both operands have the same type and the
same value
so
you can understand this more with this
piece of code so suppose
in this case
since they both are equal it will return
true while in this case they both have
the
same
type hence it will return true now
let us
next check this equals to equal so since
they both are one and in php it will
display as true since they are equal
while when you are type checking that is
you are checking if they're equal with
the same type and same value it will
display a false since one is an integer
and the other one is a string value
also if you check two different strings
with the type save it will also display
true
next question
how does exception handling work in php
so when an exception is thrown
code following the statement will not be
executed and php will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a php fatal
error will be issued with an uncaught
exception and exception can be thrown
and caught within php
so what we do is we use this try and
catch
method to
try the code and if an error occurs we
can catch
if an exception occurs we can throw it
and the catch function will catch
the exception and if doesn't we do not
include the catch function it will
result in a fatal error
next up
differentiate between require and
include now require if a required file
is not found it will throw a fatal error
and stop the code execution while in
case of include if an essential file is
not found it will produce a warning and
still execute the remaining scripts so
as you can see both of these include and
require i use in the exact same way with
different functions next up
explain different types of errors in php
now php consists of mainly three errors
notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it
a warning is a critical error now it is
given in condition where suppose an
include function
that we just discussed in the previous
question
then to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning
and final is a fatal error so it is a
critical error resulting in termination
of the code so as we discuss in the try
and catch part of the question if
an exception is thrown and we do not
have a catch function for it it will
display a fatal error which will return
in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference
so ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value passed inside the function
is also modified while in case of value
the
value of the original
value does not change
so this piece of code here is
an example of how you can call a
function by reference here as you can
see this ampersand sign will call this
function by reference and any changes
made in the variables here
will affect the original ones next
question
create a singleton class in php so how
do we create a singleton class in ph
before that let's have a look at what is
a singleton class now a singleton class
in php is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create
different access points into that block
of code so in a singleton class you can
only create a single object hence
singleton so this piece of code as you
can notice is used to create a singleton
class
now in to create a singleton class
you need to have the constructor
function private
now here
as you can see a singleton class is
created using this private construct
and it then
checks
if there's only one instance created and
if it is
it functions properly and displays
initialize only once next question
how to encrypt a password using php so
php
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose you create a
password string and enter your password
as password address one two three and
you put it inside the password has hash
function
so what it will generate is we are
echoing this generated hash
so what it will generate is
this so this is the
this is random it changes every time you
generate the password since it is
encrypted and
same when you pass
this password to the database using
hashing algorithm even in the database
the password will not be visible so your
data is secure
next question
mention different sorting functions for
errors in php now let us understand this
question in the vs code so
php consists of different sorting
functions which you can use to sort and
give an array automatically so if you
want to sort an array in ascending order
what you need to do is use this sort
function so it will sort this array in
ascending order now if you want to sort
it in descending order
use our sort that is reverse sort
similarly suppose you want to
sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this so in terms
of value what in terms of value means is
suppose in a given error there are keys
and values so it will sort the array
based on the values that is this 22 27
and 37 so the array will be the same
since
the values are already sorted now if you
want to sort the array in according to
key that is this
you can use k sort that is key sort
function that is provided in php so in
case of key sort
what it does is it will sort the array
in key that is the first one would be d
that is duke second m mac and the third
r that is raw
now
if you want to sort
this
array
in descending order in terms of value
you use instead of a sort you use a
reverse sort similarly if you want to
sort an array in terms of key
in descending
you use k instead of k sort k r sort
that is k reverse sort so these are the
different sorting functions that are
inbuilt into php
moving on
what will be the output of the following
code now
if this code is given
let me give you some time and try to
pause this video and think of what will
be the output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1
how did it happen
but before that if you got it correct
congratulations
but if you want to understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference
now we make changes in the b variable
with 2
followed by this variable again which is
calling the value of a by reference so
if we make changes here we also make
changes in the value of a now if we
display this since the value of a is
already changed by reference it will
display 2 1 that is the value here and
again since the value of b is already 2
1 it will again display 2 1.
moving on
what our construct function and destruct
function in php
so a constructor or construct function
is automatically invoked when a new
object of a class is created and then
can be used to initialize value in class
so when you create a object
an object for a class a constructor
function is automatically invoked
but this can also be so it does not
contain any value when it is invoked but
you can also use this construct function
to initialize some properties to give
some properties to the class
which will act as its default properties
if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a destruct now a distract is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is destructed suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources
next
is how can php and javascript interact
now php and javascript can not directly
interact with each other since php is a
server-side scripting language while
javascript is a client-side language
but there is a way that these two
wonderful languages can interact with
each other so we can swap variables
since php can produce javascript code to
be implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce javascript code from php
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to php
via a url
next question is
explain type hinting in php
now in php type hinting is used to
specify the expected data type that is
array object interface etc for an
argument in a function declaration
now during a function call suppose if
argument does not match the expected
data type the run time will display an
error and the pro that is a fatal error
and the program will then terminate now
in this code here what we are doing is
we are type hinting so this is this code
is for string type hinting
and this code is for integer type
hinting now if these
particular set of functions that have
already specified the type they are
expecting does not
receive the same type of variable inside
them
the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate
so
moving on to our final question of this
video
write a class so yes this is a an
assignment a kind of assignment for you
guys so what you need to do is you need
to write a class to solve the following
question which i'm going to say so
implement a class named basketball we
all like basketball right so implement a
class name basketball with an attribute
named baskets so you have to create an
attribute named baskets and initialize
it to 0 as the starting position
and then
create a method named score now when the
score method is invoked the baskets must
increase by 1. so let's see the solution
now so this is how you create a class
that is basketball
now
inside this class what we are going to
do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we're going to do is we will
be using construct function as we
discussed to initialize some
default properties for the class so this
construct function is
used to initialize this
basket's
variable to 0. now suppose we do not
call this function score which is
increasing the number of baskets
the default value will be displayed as
zero every time now suppose we invoke
this core function every time a basket
is code
this will increase the number of baskets
by one
so this is pretty simple and this is how
you create a simple class which will
perform
the following question
so that's it guys for the full course
tutorial on php programming i do hope
you have liked it if you did do hit the
like button and subscribe to simply
learn for more such content
thank you for watching stay tuned and
keep learning
you